welcome everybody to the h3 podcast with
a very very special guest in town for
VidCon is your boy buggy well I'll be
honest with you I am actually here for
this podcast VidCon yeah yeah I'll be
honest with you when we were playing at
VidCon this year you you mentioned the
podcast more like six months ago said
you want to be on it and like the next
time I'm in LA but that's the entire
thing I thought the whole time I was
afraid to approach you
I was like I'm gonna demon just demand
to be on it but I'm like well I know
he's busy and I was like you got so flow
this Friday isn't it steve-o this Friday
so flow next Friday I said you like a
packed schedule anyway it fits you in
time well not a lot of people can I'm a
big guy unless you know that I happen to
be a little extra wide we got all the
space you need by well for me it's like
I know you don't you don't get the
opportunity to come out to LA free for
you although you have been traveling
more well we've been trying to but this
body does not like it very much anymore
it started to you know it's been a
downhill battle I'd like to say uphill
battle but it's been a downhill battle
over the last couple years with diabetes
getting worse blood pressure getting
worse and everything else so it's
difficult to even really leave the house
anymore that's busted out back these
busted knees and stuff like that but we
push it to its absolute limits and we
try to come out to LA at least twice a
year at least for the game Wars at least
for VidCon I think now I'm I don't know
if you know listeners know this but I'm
scheduled for gastric bypass in July
25th yeah I and it was a three year
process to qualify holy [ __ ] so we had
to lose a ton of weight to get down to
an idea how much how so when you decided
that you wanted to get the gastric
bypass surgery yeah how much weight did
you need to lose seize them
well okay well the very when I knew that
I was gonna I when I liked finally came
to terms the fact that I would need
gastric my best I was 13 years ago oh
but then like financially I couldn't
afford it to begin with how much is it
well I mean in 13 years ago you're
talking about you fifty sixty thousand
dollars you know right and that's just
like I've surd and I couldn't get
insurance and I only work I get was
part-time and generally us your like
nepotism through friends and stuff yes
did people don't to put me on their
health insurance that's crazy right
right and so I knew that was the first
step and to finally get enough money in
the bank to be able
to pay for it so the doctor I'm working
with if you're living the Northwest
Arkansas region dr. Turner is an amazing
doctor
he managed it coming a really nice deal
it's right under 20,000 and it's on a
pocket you know but you have health
insurance I do I we bought the best
possible package Arkansas offers but
they they don't want to pay for that
surgery the considered to be a cosmetic
surgery which sounds like lunacy to me
because it will save them millions Lee
you know if they were doing that surgery
pay $18,000 to keep me from having a
stroke or a heart attack yeah and like
how much is that gonna cost you well
right but it you know but politics aside
then I but I have my biggest I was 600
pounds as your just right under 600
pounds then I've long and then went back
up to 560 and then back down to 500 and
then back up to 550 then back down to
500 and yeah and I managed to trend
downwards on like an average but it said
that yo-yo thing a lot of people my size
tend to do that just like with the with
how life what life throws at you
sometimes you just I mean I know that
feeling on a micro-level
right like I tried I have I have a
little bit of like a fat guy disease I
always think because like ela doesn't
care about food but I get it in my mind
like when I just I need a [ __ ]
cheeseburger or I need to eat some [ __ ]
and I don't have that self control like
ela doesn't care about food but for me
it's it is kind of I guess it's kind of
therapeutic I will tell you now I just
this um I want to confront you with
right away you've called yourself the
Fupa king of YouTube are you kidding me
dude let me tell you something you ain't
got nothing on me listen I haven't your
Papa got I haven't seen my dick and so
long I could have it declared legally
dead you understand okay listen to me I
was taking a piss the other day and
which is by the way all guesswork I'm
sorry for what I did your bathroom
before the show but listen I I heard a
clink of the glass hitting porcelain and
I just passed a kidney stone took a step
back looked in the toilet there's a tiny
little bottle scooped it out inside the
tiny little bottle was a tiny little
note and the note said dear Steve please
send [ __ ] sincerely your prick so I
know he's out there as an SOS right
please somebody
that's [ __ ] hilarious all right I'm
not at that level yet but I'm not that
many cheeseburgers away from never seen
my dick again yeah I don't know I see
now I'm self-conscious of other people's
weight so I watched you
you've been slim it down a little bit
man but it's like you were saying good
it's looking good good it's like you're
saying I lost like 25 pounds right in a
month and then I got sick and I just
like lost all [ __ ] I was just like
I'm sick I didn't eat for a week [ __ ]
this and then that was like a month ago
and I've been putting on weights and I
probably gained like five pounds back
and that's like that's yeah that's what
everybody does right and that's the
biggest problem with once you get big
it's so hard to not be big yeah and like
you'll see people who hit these record
weight losses I have a friend whose name
I'm never supposed to mention but he was
on a television show Extreme Makeover a
weight loss edition right and he ended
up on the show and he ended up losing a
dramatic amount of weight like record
announced the way hundreds hundreds
putting I think one of the most record
losses just period ever in the air and
of course like every other contestant
that you read about on Biggest Loser
every other contestant he gets home and
puts half that weight back on or in some
cases people put all of that weight back
on or even some cases he put another 100
or 200 and like that's one of the
reasons I and getting the surgeries
because I want to be an advocate for it
easy for a lot of people who's
somebody's like what 50 pounds
overweight like you are maybe 75 pounds
overweight jeez isn't that when
somebody's like that that's that big are
you not
they probably like I'm just kidding I'm
just but I would imagine you probably
your biggest 50 pounds over your ideal
weight I'm probably about thirty okay
well this is something I don't think
anybody will realized to you you get
here
I did not realize exactly how tiny you
guys actually harmless to consider the
source
Yeah right but I'm always amazed when I
see someone I feel like a monster Ethan
because he always exaggerated yeah back
foot forward is so good I mean the one
so good one
I consistently hear when I meet people
for the first time is one you're
skinnier than I thought and then the
other one is today I think you're I
think that's it sexy fat and you
actually you're not as funny as I
thought constantly stop hanging out with
me for 10 minutes say you're really not
as funny as I never thought you were
funny man that's good yeah don't worry
but I want more proper introduction oh
yeah oh what's up ladies and gentleman
of YouTube booked into 988 coming at you
live once again through the power of the
Internet tonight now I want to talk to
you a little bit about my friends Ethan
and good wine who show is the hit start
taking over hey guys it's me Francesca
this is actually my real voice the focus
there as you cared no tears would that
be awesome
new proper introduction uh well I mean
you need no intro buggy to 988 he's a
legend of YouTube he's been around
forever he's well he's a [ __ ] legend
and I think everybody you know your
reputation exceeds you precedes precedes
exceeds me probably appropriate I don't
know one of the seeds it's seeding
something and then of course you heal
Klein if in case you don't know him
check out his channel of course not he's
a legend I mean when I do twitch to for
the people watching us which don't know
oh yeah you played over Wi-Fi nights we
and I will tell you let's talk about
something by the way I'm glad to see you
finally coming over to twitch but where
were you four years ago when I was
telling everybody the ad pocalypse is
coming shift for diversify you were
safai where you're four years ago
antennas we weren't really on YouTube to
be honest that short of a time we've
been we're making like $100 a month on
YouTube for years ago yeah like four
years ago we were uploading some but we
weren't like doing YouTube dude you want
to see what we were uploading four years
ago I think I swear I've seen it it was
my art projects basically let me show
you what we were what you doing for
years honey because I was saying I I
think I've been following you now I
guess the majority of your career
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I was so
embarrassing I'm sorry but like I said I
think I've been following you guys since
I saw you on reddit the first time and I
don't know is your first time on like
such our such videos but may i we binge
watch everything we have my friends are
very Saturday night and we tend to binge
watch YouTube a little bit and Eric from
Comet etiquette is a bit of jacksFilms
back on these do love them the grammar
your grammar sucks
and then we somebody I'm like let's
check out let's check out these guys for
straight hours
that's just kept coming back and so we
watch your entire catalog did and we've
followed you ever since it must be isn't
it crazy when you hear that I mean it
must be the same for you when you hear
that people actually sit at home and
watch your videos what's insane it's
pretty wild it's so what's insane to me
is that actually like that you guys even
know who I am or I'm just saying a good
story for you okay I have to hear what
I'm saying like when you create on
YouTube and I live in Arkansas right now
I don't have the New York connection or
the LA collect connection right and I
I'm loose I've always been a recluse I
spent seven years as a shut-in once man
I don't generally like people very much
and my wife really brought me out of
that shell completely but I've always
been good with people but that was just
like - I was good at getting away from
people like even me one arms-length and
so I creating this like vacuum right and
you get all that negative stuff I get a
lot of negative stuff because my size
because my opinion sometimes a lot of
the Xbox kids hate me because I like
PlayStation or vice versa you know and
that's the real hey estimate gets in
your head you know oh yeah so it
exacerbates and I go crazy and then I
come to something like VidCon and then I
get to meet creators like you who I'm
watching every day and I respect like
you can't imagine like last year I had
dinner with Burnie burns and I've been
watching Burnie burns since yeah vs.
blue in 1998 really cool that we were
streaming
red vs. blue and 240 people walking
around quoting that and the late 90s I
guess or maybe early 2000s it's insane
when the people that you love and
respect and watch every day you love and
respect you yeah yes that's that to be
in this room is just mind-boggling to me
well let me put in perspective for you
okay because when
one of the it's almost embarrassing or
it's not really embarrassing but just
gives you some idea of like where
everyone starts we were we started in
Israel and it's also just such an
awesome thing about YouTube is that you
can do it anyway remember the reason
that I really went after YouTube I was
watching Jimmy Kimmel and he was saying
some [ __ ] about how if you make good
stuff in this day and age because
traditionally was like you had to know
somebody you had to have somewhere to
send your [ __ ] you had to suck
somebody's dick he's like these days
with YouTube if you make good stuff and
just put it on the internet people will
watch it and I was like damn that's
that's really that struck me so I
decided I want to do YouTube cuz I don't
have any connections or anything but I
know I want to be entertainment anyway I
loved your earlier work by the way the
earlier job is so weird it's very
different I loved watching I loved
watching you grow into yourself but
really this is chill
this is the story it's insane to watch
um you know I I thought for sure yours
me like over the corner I walked in here
today because I mean you were so
uncomfortable in the front of the camera
oh yeah hell he was making you do it at
the mic
should I call a spousal services to make
sure she's not like a couple of thousand
plug see now she's happy this is for
your own good thank you
we do love ya I think I'd speak for
everybody when we say that what you
would people don't care about me anymore
it's all about Mila client for life I
was saying I think before we like
officially started this dream I was
telling you that it's it's daily for me
like I'm still yeah I still I can't even
watch myself it's really hard by the way
me too
I have exactly yeah I have [ __ ] a lot
of trouble sometimes like it's not you
know there everyone's full of neurotic
people everyone's neurotic to a certain
extent it's just some I feel like I'm
pretty neurotic too - I will say because
of the nature of what I talk about on
YouTube for the people who are listening
to don't know me very well I do like a
bunch of stupid comedy stuff with the
Francis character and I talk about
games a lot but every once in a while
like dip down into the personal stuff
and you know there's a period of time in
life where I was suicidal so I talked
about that on YouTube and I get a ton of
letters because that people you know I
have some really good stories of some
really bad stories you know I won't bore
you with too many of them but then I
talk about you know what it's like to be
a big guy and there's a lot of big
people out there right now struggling
with their weight by the way I'm not a
health at any size er I think that's one
of the biggest [ __ ] scams of the
world you can be healthy at any size for
a little while but that eventually does
catch up that bill becomes due by the
way kids yeah you know and when I got on
YouTube
I wanted to serve at the very least is a
bad example date don't do what I did
people because I'm miserable isn't my
original plan but when it comes to the
anxieties I lost track it's gonna make
their um we were talking about and we're
all neurotic right was it there so the
number of youtubers who will open up to
me when I get that five minutes was just
a VidCon and obviously I'm not gonna
betray anybody's trust yeah yeah like
they'll say oh I saw that video and had
hit me because I've had suicidal
tendencies or I've had did I've been
there kind of things either right I'll
talk about it all I want to talk about
it I think it's interesting so people
know that we're all humans right I will
tell you I genuinely believe genuinely
believe that there's not a youtuber in
the world that publishes a video and
goes I'm very satisfied with that happen
maybe once or twice in the history of
our tale usually it's like it's like
[ __ ] usually when we post a video it's
like oh [ __ ] this I can't work on this
any longer
I need this out of my life I need this
out of my life right now I've been I
created my account in 2006 and I started
making videos at the end of 2010 eight
ish right
I started making put videos about 2008
ish and then around 2010 is where I
started taking it serious matter no I
met my wife I've met the girl is gonna
become my wife
and I'm like man I need to like not just
screw around on this thing I need to see
if I can make something of it but I've
never been satisfied with my work and
never like anything I've ever done every
time I put it out in the world I'm like
this is it I've ruined everything that
video was in the
and my wife God loves so funny she has
to endure this once every three months
because I mean you know you you know now
of course you've had a meteoric rise so
certainly you probably don't know I
watched your YouTube stats go boom like
it's just a we have like plateaus and
and strikes strikes and gutters well
I've always had that oh but I checked
your social blade I cannot [ __ ]
believe how like you've chugged along
because you hit four million subscribers
yeah and that's over the course of like
seven years and just like steady
grinding right that is that's what it
what perspective all did well I have a
history in web design and search engine
optimizations so every once in while the
algorithm will have a new problem with
my channel they'll have a problem with
the way I'm uploading the frequency that
I'm uploading or the topics that I'm
talking about and I have to completely
reinvent myself and but I'm pretty good
at figuring out an algorithm and pretty
good at figuring out what they need to
deliver my videos though isn't that
[ __ ] up about YouTube that you're not
like hey do people like my videos it's
all about like is YouTube trying to kill
my channel this week by the way and just
people I'm afraid when I talk about the
algorithm killing my channel people can
think I'm like a whiny conspiracy
theorist this [ __ ] is real er real and
the worst part about it is when you talk
to a Google engineer every once in a
while and I have several things I get
hacked at VidCon last year yeah and so I
got to really get to know the Google
engineer team the one engineer by the
name of Jeff if you're listen hi he took
his day off at VidCon to sat down with
me for four and a half hours to restore
as much as he couldn't it still took
five weeks night to get everything back
together to where I could read up load
and everything but that you know during
that process we talked about all kinds
of stuff and then I talked to some of
the other youtubers that are connected
as well obviously won't betray any names
or anything yeah a prophet they they'll
talk about the algorithm and the guys at
YouTube they know right but the way
Google seems to operate based on what
I've heard secondhand or the way YouTube
seems to operate it's the same way that
Google operates there's not a lot of of
there's not just one boss
and everybody kind of works in these
little pods and so my friend Jeff worked
for the notification team and like well
who's your boss he's kind of like well
kind of I don't know it's poorly about
yeah yeah and they know they don't talk
about the inner workings at all they're
super secretive and like every time I've
spoken to a Google employee it they'll
be like you can't ever say this publicly
this is strictly confidential and then
they'll say something it's not even
interesting and I'm like what the [ __ ]
tell me the good [ __ ] but but it appears
that they it's just like one hand never
knows what the other hand is doing
and so that's entirely possible yeah and
it's like we will all break off in our
own little pods and like someone came up
with the idea of the notification idea
that wasn't like handed down from Susan
or something that's just somebody came
up with and I went and built it then
showed it to their boss and that boss is
like one stalled on the website let's
see what happens yeah and so since
they're just pushing out new code and
different times in different places even
they don't really know what's gonna
happen and they know that we get tore up
right but they also know the resilient
ones will find a way well figured well
it's all about money I mean that's not
exactly true I think of what I
understood but the thing is that I
learned from talking to engineers I
don't think this is confidential it's
not but it's all like machine learning
so a lot of times what I learned what
should actually shocked me is that they
don't even know what's happening because
the algorithm is machine learning and
it's constantly tweaking itself
there's no longer the engineers aren't
even involved at this point they just
like check up on it periodically to try
to understand what it's doing right but
I think a lot of people there actually
don't even understand what's happening
which is such a shame because when
Google was brand new and I was doing
that web design I started doing um just
like silly fan pages on like Angel Fire
and I know nobody knows what that is or
a target how Hugh cities your mafia and
eventually discovered like I was I
started designing for clients with just
basic HTML and then eventually like they
open that up to India and there's so
many skilled coders in India they're
more skilled to me other work north a
fraction of the price yeah so I couldn't
compete so I worked on search engine
optimization and I realized that all
these little stupid pages that I created
I could figure out which ones are
getting to the top of Google searches
then sell that information and they
would only update the algorithm every
three
so I crack it two weeks in to push it
out to my clients and they'd all push
back a thousand bucks for the
information this was pre it is right I
said boy this was Hitler's provide
Katzie 97-98 right but then they started
like rotating algorithms and so you
never knew what was going to be active
that day so I could sell you the key to
one algorithm but it didn't mean
anything
you could affect what is that the key to
an algorithm so basically it would wait
different things at different times so
today we're looking at this parameter or
that parameter today we're looking for
these particular keywords that they hire
or we're parsing this particular part of
the language differently or we're
looking for words and headers and we're
looking for words and bold or we're
looking for bolts and tables and we're
looking at tables and so you could
figure out what specifically Google was
high-ranking at that period of time but
how did you make money like you justify
somebody you wanted that information is
crying because oh you were just giving
information something's gonna be
trending tomorrow right so you buy that
or more specifically way that you would
format the webpage is specifically what
I would be sewing and so I would figure
out very quickly that all of the pages
that I had that had tables built in or
that one was performing well wha the
pages that had frames built in so that
was not performing and so I could push
out to those people so back then it was
even more like web page exactly right
and so translates a little bit to
YouTube oh yeah but not same algorithm I
have no Matt Pat from game theorist that
guy is I don't know he's insane when it
comes to like the YouTube algorithm and
stuff that I just did I went to a small
convention I go to it every year called
retro Palooza it's in Texas and I'm it's
real small it's the game chasers I know
nobody probably knows him that well but
they're just a great group of people and
just want to play a party with so I go
down to it and one year they got Matt
Pat from the game theorists to come
which is like a super weird number one I
normally headline that thinks I was mad
matt was there but secondly this young
lady in the audience she says I'm having
some trouble on YouTube trying to get my
stuff seen and I don't really know what
I'm doing wrong and so can you help me
with that
and I'm thinking she wants that normal
inspirational answer like you know be
consistent yeah and stay true to your
sign come on make contact it yeah right
they come to the people engage with you
try to figure out what your virals gonna
be do what you know that's not Matt
that's not Matt Matt is like alright so
do you have a pen and paper let's start
talking about the header alright so in
in the title of the video you need to
include at least six to eight keywords
now in the description second I don't
believe in that [ __ ] can we talk about
the text alright now here's the thing
nobody realizes this yet but the
algorithm now looks at your thumbnails
30 minutes 30 minutes I'm just reading
her the google playbook like I is
actually a really nice guy I guess the
thing is okay I have dude I've been
trying to understand that [ __ ] for a
long time I think we've come to the
point though where thumbnail title
definitely matters but not in terms of
of getting suggested all that matters is
hey are you gonna get monetized right
yeah the algorithm is now just basically
a game of Ken this video raw ads or not
yep the search this the suggestions is a
total [ __ ] show like it's just based on
I think like your click-through rate
which that information is not available
to us
no and it's an impression so I mean like
how it's a search engine optimization
guy I hate I'm a bit we're born but like
a lot of your audience right now
impression how many people saw the page
how many people saw the thing though
don't know how many people I offered the
link yeah I don't have that information
I can't figure out what the
click-through rate I can't well there's
a page and and they won't tell me how
many times that's why they don't tell
you because that's the real right
missing piece said to the equation
click-through rate is probably the
single most important factor and you
know they don't tell you that because
they don't want you click baiting but
it's like people are gonna [ __ ] it's
like bait its kind and so basically if
you've got a video on the sidebar and
it's getting clicked more they do a test
on every video right this is my theory I
don't know this so they'll show you for
like a thousand views and if people
nobody clicks it then you don't
you go away right and there's like new
rounds I feel like every like 10,000
views depending on how many views you're
getting so reassess your video every
10,000 views and see what's the
click-through rate on the sidebar on
this suggested right if and it just
keeps going and keeps going and then
that's how you get some videos with like
50 million views just from being spam
you ever been suggested a video so much
it like follows you everywhere was a
video YouTube likes bagged unanimously
was on every video I created for a year
it was you know it had like 93 million
views yeah and it was 8 1 minute long
video of an eight-year-old child
swimming underwater every video I
created that got recommended number one
is I know why it's because my number one
most viewed video is me falling
backwards and yes must have the most
insane click-through rate for whatever
reason people are clicking the [ __ ] out
of that otherwise YouTube wouldn't show
it so it's on one hand it's all about
that click-through rate and then the
other like it used to be tags
it used to be description that [ __ ]
doesn't matter at all tags is just
they're just a dupe to tag yeah it's it
Casey nice
ok so nice that doesn't use tags really
he doesn't use any tax and he hasn't for
years and that guys in trending every
other day a little another conspiracy by
the way but like so they don't use tags
is literally just entrapment well I
thought that it it can serve as a
positive thing in that like if I talk
about a video game I will always include
PlayStation 4 Xbox one Xbox X 1x X Box 1
s Nintendo switch those keywords because
you don't have a maybe you should get it
because people are saying volume up
how's the volume out there Carlos
okay so never mind getting trolled no
okay good
but I think that the the advertiser
bought does look at that for choosing
what ads will get displayed if so I
decided I do think that's wrong I think
right now all that matters is the title
and the thumbnail probably if you have
Xbox in the title that's probably 99%
that makes sense I think tags are litter
because people stuff the [ __ ] out of
tags forever they I genuinely think they
only ever think about that when you put
stuff that negatively affects you I
think you're right if you put tits or
sex or [ __ ] or some stupid ass [ __ ] then
they're like oh hey how you doing thanks
for the signal right all right so at
this point it's like it's like really
intricate weird machine learning things
but mostly it's just about engagement
slash a certain amount of survival guilt
because let's say this time last year I
had gotten really frustrated with with
the face of YouTube and I knew like you
were talking about like you to drama to
extent but not like like maybe like a
keemstar kind of level of thing and keen
was doing it but he's doing in this
keemstar kind of way which I don't think
appeals to everybody I and I've always
liked defranco's way of approaching
stuff like the Franco I think it kind of
a man-crush for me he knows that now but
but I love the way he's very very
neutral down the middle about a topic
when he presents and then delivers his
opinion and I thought nobody's doing
that for YouTube drama and I I thought
man I'm gonna do that I'm gonna be that
guy and I got a lot of praise from
people I really liked but I made a video
about Toby Turner and that video did not
set well like to perpetrate what was
going on with Toby and I'm like man this
was your angle well it was just
basically to talk about what the Franco
had said to say what Toby had said in
his own defense and then just kind of
just over middle right just this is what
the Franco said this is what Tobias said
this is what the rumor mill says I don't
really know and then my personal opinion
was I feel bad for the guy you know
because it's easy to decipher like that
yeah I thought let's just all give them
a little bit of love and let's see if we
can help and figure it out but it still
didn't sell well so why didn't it sit
well because I I felt like what if Toby
saw that right like he didn't know who I
am I I saw him at VidCon the year before
and he didn't know me from Adam so but
I'm thinking what he saw that and though
I thought I could not know hey seems
like it was pretty positive right but
even then I the anxiety kind of got to
me a little bit and so the next video I
made was about Matthew Santoro who I've
talked off to off and on for years and
when he got claimed for a plagiarism
right
yeah and so I talked about you know the
transformative nature of taking a list
and making it into a video which is very
transformative right and even if it was
using that base list almost verbatim in
a court of law that might very well
stand up as transformative and the only
real angle they would have when it comes
to fair use would be attacking the the
fact that it destroys the value of the
original list no I don't think it was
ever at risk for being a copyright
infringement
it was just like kind of like oh man
right it's kind of [ __ ] but that was hey
that's how reddit took it for little
wall is that that's ridiculous like
right yeah and so I tried to dispute
that it was not ever a fair use issue
yeah it was just kind of a moral issue
and so I made that video and then I'm
like man I me and Matt have talked off
and on about some real private stuff
what if he sees that video did I I
remember you were talking about drama
back in the day or not even drama but
topical issues right then there was the
thing where you'll removed a bunch of
right you're like so a friend of a
mentor alcohol goes far as a mentor John
Bane total biscuit yeah message me on
skype one night and he's just like hey
man are you doing okay and after I made
that video or us talking about the
anxiety that I was getting from those
videos and I'm like I don't know man I
don't feel so good about what I'm doing
he goes well here's the thing man if if
something happens in my life are you
gonna make a video about it what about
Dodger about Jesse you know cuz we
talked about that okay you know it's
like you know John okay totalbiscuit has
a weird thing about drama right he's
he's the one person who's always
consistent like he had this big
conspiracy that everyone got blacklisted
because of drama channels and like
robber I don't know if I agree with that
I don't but but here's my take yeah well
actually if you if you don't mind it
that was enough to where it pushed my
anxiety off the edge and I'm like you
know what
I can make content that isn't this and
you know what I'm gonna feel a lot
better about myself I'm gonna feel a lot
more comfortable with what I'm doing
like let's get back to the roots let's
get back to the game and let's get back
to that stuff well let the experts do
that right and then when the ad
pocalypse hits my income drops 20% I
barely dropped right well you mean it
dropped to the the YouTube Horsham I had
come drop
about 20 to 30% its peak was about half
what it normally be and it's right now
about 60 or 70 percent what it was last
year and so I had like this survived it
it went down it went down mine dropped
of course everybody's dropped no but I'm
just a nurse so when the first eight you
drop 20 I've dropped like 20 then and
nonpoint ft after about 3 weeks and now
I'm back up to about 30% what I earned
last year
I was like 70% last year right and I
might eventually be back to where I was
you know with the algorithm continue to
learn of the contactor I'm creating but
I keep thinking man like I've dodged a
bullet there by you by deciding to clean
them I don't think I feel kind of bad
about it I don't think so yeah I don't
think so
I don't think that's what happened at
all you don't know well good make me
feel better if you tell me not enough
tell me what do you they go well first
of all I feel like you're always trying
to like find reasons to make yourself
feel bad I've been through that myself
no that's me that I'm not sure I don't
kill yeah just there's no your your
decision doesn't impact anybody it's
just but I don't think that drama
channels got affected one way or the
other
I was talking to some people who made
drama channels they're making more money
than ever right now and our our CPM I
think we got hit especially bad just
because we have a lot of like edge year
videos like yeah I don't know whatever
that means on YouTube like I mean you're
you're pretty safe you sit there and
Utah tonic you sit at any talk there's
nothing no it's I don't think what
matters so much is what you're talking
about it's more about like um subject
matter like the stuff that really gets
you is talking about like terror events
and [ __ ] like right exactly
that's the stuff they care about is like
making fun of feminists [ __ ] like that
right surprisingly those videos have
better CPM than any of our other ones
that seems reasonable so like that's one
of the things that I just admired about
you right like I've always I've I might
my Youtube subscriber list I think
surprises people sometimes cuz I love
idubbbz I love filthy Frank and Max mofo
and just like all the people that push
the edge of grade and like obviously you
guys too and I love the people that put
[ __ ] well the reason I've always
preferred to your content everybody
else's is that most of the time even
when you're like direct Tarun somebody
apart most of the time you're still the
butt of the joke
most of the time like I probably the
video that I think exemplifies that more
than anything I go back to the guy with
the swords cutting through shades yeah
and stuff steak and like you just like
you inhaled that guy pun intended
oh you impaled that guy you ruined him
he just followed me on Twitter by the
way like a week ago
but in the same in the same video then
there's you like flipping around in your
front yard a dog turns you know at the
end of that video you're not even really
thinking about that anymore you're
laughing at you that's like I like I
really appreciate off of whoever you're
focusing on right and when you do put
heat on someone it's always in it's
never hate its memes right like when
when idubbbz goes after somebody I mean
it is yeah Wow like that's just
straight-up
great school level bullying sometimes
which I love sometimes as long as it's
funny for you it's always it's always
it's memes that's I appreciate that
swing with memes and I love that I
really appreciate it it's definitely
something we tried it sometimes we like
I think that's like creating everyone
has their different personality right
and so whatever they're making has
something of their personality in it yep
and I feel like for the both of us it's
really hard to just like which just
maybe we're mean to someone we don't
like that feeling right so back in the
day like we always I love for example
Ian's content oh yes I love it but I
couldn't make it myself right stupid I
feel like like the video made about Tana
oh yeah I did contemplate him like man
did he go in too hard but at but I guess
that's that's his style
right yeah and he brings it to that
point we were like [ __ ] did he go
through more like my favorite show on
television I hope you've seen that
Nathan for you soon oh my god it's
[ __ ] brilliant yeah it's like the
semi reality he goes to businesses and
he tries to help them but he just makes
everything worse but it's like a reality
show they don't know that he's like
doing a bear character but he pushes it
so far sometimes that you get really
uncomfortable that's my sense of humor
that's exactly my sense of your senior
very uncomfortable and my roots are in
like Richard Pryor
kinnison Eddie Murphy and like 80s Eddie
Murphy if you never listen to the lyrics
is one of my favorite right but it's
like today I have trouble listening to
that it made me feel uncomfortable in
the 80s now it makes me want to like
turn off I'm like oh my god you can't
say those words even Eddie Murphy can't
say those words you can't say that right
um it's just insane but that's that's
always been my comedic style so I
started on YouTube that's what I wanted
to do right like I wanted to be like Fat
Boy get later all right I'm the whole
Nick I'm gonna get naked the joke is I'm
fat that's always gonna be the joke yeah
and I don't know one day I just was a
depressed mood sat down turn on the
camera just started talking to it and
and and then I was like therapy for me
and then people responded to that way
more than I responded any like me eating
meat weirdly or I was watching recently
some of your classic like the Mountain
Dew taste test video I love you like
[ __ ] oh my god I was like god this is
just hilarious [ __ ] the part where
you're like he's he's in the video
testing there's like eight different
flavors of Mountain Dew and towards the
end you're like oh yeah this one tastes
like diabetes I can feel my toes
tingling I like that I was like man that
is those rolls and those were always
like just a riff off the cup off the
cuff like Gotti reminded me of opens
reminds me of the old school videos we
used to make just like the Wild West
[ __ ] you know the stick of those was
always to be believable I wanted someone
to think that's a real that wasn't
really something that was the brilliance
of Francis and then eventually I had
this boiling point where everyone was
into the joke right and so when I did
that I was like well now it's time to be
a little more transformative with the
character because no one's I mean
everybody's heard of me now if you you
know even even the new faces of YouTube
don't find it believable like the young
kids or whatever and I don't want I
don't want preteens watching my content
anyway right you know so I know the
number of times I swear in Francis video
so I tried to I try to be transformative
with it I think it still works a lot of
people prefer like the voice changed
dramatically because it used to be a
very I don't they still do it but it's a
ago she what Killip it could be Francesc
it I is very low
then I wanted to try to make a little
more cartoony so it kind of hey guys
what's up me free action let me tell you
something I don't know
and I really prefer that way of doing it
and I have like some comedic inflection
inflection in it and it sounds much more
like a cartoon character
it's bit less believable yeah but still
to this day like my e3 content this year
I really really wanted to do III right
it's all the Francis sketches for e3
I've wrote as many jokes as I could and
my wife sitting down next me writing
jokes with me too and tried to go very
old-school with it and I got a brand new
group of people in who then the very
first e3 video I uploaded with my
regular voice they're like what the [ __ ]
what like people mad still they get mad
do you say they like the idea that
Francis is real oh god is so convincing
so I think the first time I saw France
maybe I thought it was real oh you're
making my day right now
no but well this was like back early
days a YouTube and that [ __ ] was like
all over the place
the francese Ray's videos were like was
such a character was such a meme I was
like a beautiful part of YouTube's
history was the Francis rage but to go I
was I was about to tell sorta I think
you'd be flattered well yeah it's
interesting it's kind of embarrassing
for me but we regardless so back in the
day when we had like I don't know 500
subscribers whatever I remember you made
a video this is just like you were like
you made a video about how to grow your
channel mm-hmm and one of the tests was
to like reach out to other youtubers or
something yeah and so back in the day I
like sent you a message on YouTube oh
god just want to say I'm a fan and it's
really one of these really
quintessential yeah I don't think you
knew about it but like you get these
messages all the time I mean people I
think Big Easy's all the time like these
really quintessential cringy like hey
I'm a fan check out my [ __ ] as I sent
you one of those you're the only person
I ever sent I sent you want Garamond you
got me okay but it's completely dude
because I would tell you to this day I
block out an hour hour every day to
respond to as many people it was a
YouTube direct message oh those are hard
to find that's how long ago
but like literally because I respond it
becomes insurmountable I can't right
yeah that's what like we have a we still
have a P o box but if I ever mentioned
in the video yeah it's a it's a roomful
of yeah you can't do it like it's
impossible I that's amazing I can't
believe it was like I did it I wrote it
oh my god that was so stupid I shouldn't
do that
it felt just really dumb it's adorable
but I was just oh you know back then you
do it you [ __ ] you're out there and
now we're best friends for now looks
yeah I mean it is kind of surreal though
that I went from writing you that
cringey ass hey check out my videos
right but that's the thing like you know
what I probably have it on my computer I
think that's the only damn I've ever
sent on YouTube I got to kind of pull
that up here's the thing like the next
PewDiePie oh I'm probably better than
fine no offense Felix but the next
PewDiePie that again Mike's number one
youtuber could very well be you in the
audience right now right they could be
very well chugging along and I think
it's still possible I know what you're
about to say I think it is still
possible if you get the fundamentals
right oh yeah Logan and Jake Paul right
yeah you got he's got to number one
figure out what people want to see
number two you gotta figure out
something you can do that no one else is
doing or that you can do better than
anybody else right if you do that like
you know video game wing was not a thing
on YouTube at one point and it became a
thing because a handful of pioneers made
it a thing right yeah fidget spinners
were nothing but I mean you know I it's
so fun I think back to three years ago
at VidCon and I'm listening to to Susan
doing her little address and she's
talking about gaming on YouTube and how
to become the number one category on the
platform create and she's like what will
be the next surprise category that comes
around the corner well it turned out it
was like leafy hate speech but it was
that died off fest thank God yeah really
bad you know what I I don't know if I I
feel like I took that very personally
that whole thing because I don't want it
to my own horn but I I think we kind of
pop realized that genre can I say that
no I can believe that I have agreed yeah
when we like reaction videos like when
we started there were only reaction
videos like jinx style where people sit
and watch the videos have been around
forever
those are always been around and then
when I when we started we felt like
there was no one that's actually
commenting and like putting in this
effort is putting some effort into it so
that's how I remember it I don't know if
maybe someone else was doing well but
when we started pranksters were super
popular and basically when we had our
first big break and when I got super
passionate about making videos it came
from me watching these prank videos
getting millions of views and I was like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is so stupid and nobody's
talking about it so like it all our
channel was kind of born from that and I
think for a long time I remember
thinking we were slamming all the
pranksters from Vitaly to prank invasion
right and there was no one else doing it
and then after being successful at that
for like a year then like all these
commentary channels started propping up
yep and they were doing it like [ __ ]
like just really lazy and daily and I
was like [ __ ] these guys are kind of
ruining my [ __ ] I like kind of stopped
making reaction videos for a long time
because I'm like this is so sterile
everyone said well I would see somebody
compare what you did to that right and
when they do that someone would like it
see it and read it and someone
immediately be like but he actually
that's nice
transform he actually transforms the
antenna right and in some cases even so
much as replicates it and then someone
and adds to it and that's the difference
between what you and anybody else in
that category ever did was at the very
least at the very least there was
generally more commentary than there was
the original video and you very rarely
showed the entire video and then I were
the one who gets sued but when you
you're the guy who popularized costumes
and and sketches written around it and
recreating it and of course flopping
around a dog hurts in your front yard or
everyone's doing that right right that's
what that's what always drew me to your
content so when people would ever lump
you in I would always see somebody
immediately and if they didn't I would I
would you know my little secret reddit
account where I post
well here's the thing that still it's a
very transformative integer and I think
that's so important right I mean it
again again
like I said you know you don't hit hard
yet that's the it would mean obviously
that's the thing that bothered me the
most is like there's kind of a lot of
responsibility that comes with that and
when we first started we had under a
hundred thousand we're making reaction
videos we could talk [ __ ] and take shots
at anybody because we were punching up
legs so hard right and then it came to a
point where we had a couple million and
we had this realization like we just
always think I wonder if this person
will see our video and then we came to
this point where we realized they're
going to see our video they're like
within 5 minutes yeah and and I need to
make sure that I'm not I don't want to
[ __ ] anyone's life up I don't want it
yeah I know
and so they came out and deed they
didn't have any moral thoughts didn't
have any scruples they would [ __ ] on
anybody they would say anything and they
were just they were [ __ ] I mean
YouTube was a really horrible place for
a long time yeah yeah and when that it
all to me really came to a head with the
Tommy NC incident yeah like that was the
one that I was like are we we had we at
the line now is yeah that's where this
is where it happened right that whole
situation was [ __ ] because like they
were all blurring the lines like
keemstar was talking to him about how
he's fine he's has fake autism remember
that kisser was on this crusade he
doesn't actually it's like because I
didn't know keemstar was just riding
leafy's dick the whole time and I have a
story actually again but good for Tommy
no it happened with another kid with
autism that really made fun yeah after
Tommy I talked about responsibility on
YouTube so I will go ahead and say all
of this is alleged because I also this
is proven I'd you were saying but I made
a Francis video right at this push me
for like 7 or 50,000 subs this video
alone almost pushing her like 7 or
50,000 subs to like half a million
Wow alright sorry for 752 1.5 million
double myself but it was that whole Xbox
vs PlayStation era where they're coming
out with the Xbox one of the coming out
of the PlayStation 4 and the console
wars are really raging and so there's
gentleman by the name
by the name of Adam worth hi or T if
you're watching this is all alleges
please don't sue me are you saying this
is version of story as I know it okay
he started mouthing off on on Twitter
about him and a friend we're talking on
Twitter thinking no one would ever see
it and they're talking about how the
Xbox one is going to be an always online
device and people are like sending him
questions like well here's the thing I
don't have a good internet where I live
in a rural area how am I going to use my
xbox one and I guess why would you live
there move to a city you know and like
another guy's like oh I I'm a naval
officer on a nuclear submarine we play
xbox 360 there all the time will it work
if I don't I won't have access for six
months at a time how will it work and
he's like it won't also what's a nuclear
submarine like just being kind of mouthy
or and kind of tongue-in-cheek II but
people didn't take it that way so has
that story is breaking I make a Francis
video about it and I call him out by
name mm-hmm so the next day he gets
moved to less powerful position at
Microsoft and then soon after he resigns
and then he goes into hiding for a while
and then I hear from someone secondhand
hey do you remember a guy by the name of
Adam or no I really don't well you made
a video about him and he actually talks
about you in his speech about what it's
like to be this subject of internet hate
that he's now doing college campuses and
in corporations and I'm like really
yes I look a little bit of a [ __ ] bag
well I mean honestly okay okay if you're
gonna go from being an [ __ ] on
Twitter and poorly representing your
company and getting called out to
quitting and then doing speeches on tour
about being bullied you're kind of a
[ __ ] well maybe I mean maybe but I
his goal with the this goal with the
speeches would be just to prepare other
people for you gotta watch what you say
on the internet and if you do if you do
what didn't happen to you can happen to
me right okay so so I this guy
okay I just get it I go to the very the
very first Game Awards Jeff Keely and I
have known each other for a while Jeff's
been a fan of mine I've been a fan of
Jeff yeah a Dorito Pope the whole nine
yards I love that guy
Dorito oh yeah you don't know you never
seen that he so to get sidetracked no
yes yeah okay yeah I'm curious about the
jury it's a meme google it I don't a
sidetrack you for that I'm at the first
game awards and I'm presenting with
iJustine and Justine's just like one of
the sweetest people have ever met
and we're like playing 3d ass backstage
and just goofing off and she introduces
me to Reggie Phil ma from Nintendo and
and then Peter Moore from EA who and all
you know if you don't know Peter Moore
he's pretty much a Bond villain in real
life he's straight-up terrifying and
he's the guy who came to EA with like
the ideas of games as a service and
milking the customer and
microtransactions because he's a CEO
first a gamer last of it what a great
guy and so he presented me my game award
last year when I won turned a gamer it
was so awesome you're like [ __ ] well
we've kind of always I mean him and
Francis avoid kind of always Johnson and
so he walks up to me and it is very very
British voice I'm gonna probably this is
probably it's going to be on neogaf 30
seconds after I do this imitation of
them but like Francis have you played on
the Dragon Age like no sir I really
haven't had the time and I guess well
you'll have to make time it's got 40
hours of gameplay in the main quest
alone my 80 hours the side quests I'm
like oh please go ahead and shoot me in
the dick with a laser now is there gonna
be a dude it's gonna throw a hat to chop
my head off
which Bond villain are you today I don't
know but then he walks away and I'm like
shaking I'm just shaking cuz that guy's
scary I want to see some what's his name
let's Peter more he's scary spinet
pictures
Peter more from ETA mm-hmm and I
recently moved to he headed up there
eSports division for a while oh yeah oh
yeah look at that I think he's running a
team let me pull this oh yeah he's
running a team I I think something like
that or maybe a sports then you
definitely know dr. evil was that the
one
from right yeah now he's really no we
I've actually got to talk to him beyond
this experience and he's a nice guy but
in that instance that code he was
terrifying kill me I know that smile man
it's like it says smile this 20i so you
know he could do he could fashion the
sides of his hair into like horns almost
and get it like a little meme going
there anyway um so he walks away and I'm
just shaking like I think I may have did
he poison me I don't know I'm sorry I
ever said bad things about your company
sir and then who's standing behind them
Adam Worth and Adam Worth walks up to me
and says hey do you remember me
oh and you and I'm like yeah no I do I
remember you Adam North right he's yep
that's me and look well how are you
doing these days cos well I'm good I'm
here presenting a game for my company
and like--see landed on your feet that
huh yeah yeah and he walks away and like
that was the worst exchange of my life
he hates you right I don't know I don't
I couldn't read or home definitely held
a grudge right I'd like but he's aware
like you know and I'm like oh I need to
be careful with what I say because that
affects people's lives and even if he's
the one who took the first misstep yeah
i amplified it yeah and so what I
learned from that experience was not
only that but then I got to meet like
Major Nelson I I got to meet the guys
over PlayStation said Schumann and and
the CEO of the time I had him boys those
guys I got to know all these people what
I did not know is that the gaming
industry those people those companies
they watch my stuff all the time all the
Francis sketches they get sent from
email chains and if they have a product
coming out and I make a video about it
it that team will get sent that video
over and over and over again to the
point that Major Nelson joked and I
don't know if this is true or not
he said the engineers occasionally will
say what will Francis think about this
when they're designing stelae and then
my friend Barney Cleese nerdgasm used to
work for Microsoft confirmed that for me
so I think that's true so yeah I try to
always think I try to always think Who
am I gonna affect in this how am I gonna
affect them with this and there's that
responsibility I know it's I know you've
talked about it's hard on YouTube yeah
it's hard it's it's I have in bivolo
feelings on it because on one hand
I mean it really depends on your
approach if you're reasonable with your
response then sometimes people need to
take responsible for their own actions
great otherwise you what I can't talk
about anyone who [ __ ] up because am I
ruined like that it's like to see a
skull on a thing like those guys got
really [ __ ] up by it but it's like I
don't feel bad about that at all no in
that case cuz occasionally and like I
don't okay so he approached that video
very responsibly yeah we didn't I feel
like we didn't overstate anything we
represented the facts I think that it
was a very straightforward like
occasionally you know shitty things
eventually the bill comes to like that's
just the reality of that's right and
like I just I personally choose not to
be the person that delivers the judge
that's right that helps me sleep at
night in everything oh you're so soft
like you're such a [ __ ] yeah and like
yeah but I when the camera gets turned
off I have to live with me and so like
people like oh you let those that's a
feminist tell you what you're allowed to
say well you're not allowed to say no
not really I just know what I feel
comfortable saying dude that's totally
respectful that you make that decision
because you know that it's gonna affect
you yeah like yeah I totally relate to
that I'm like that's years ago video was
very stressful when we posted it it was
kind of scary I was when we I remember
when it went from unlisted to publish I
was like [ __ ] here we go this is gonna
be a shitstorm you know I mean like I
said man we if you're in the business of
putting [ __ ] into the world eventually
gonna have to eat your own [ __ ] like
that's the situation they found
themselves in yeah and that bill had to
come to eventually and it did yeah no no
glad you know I'm glad you pulled the
trigger on this something I always asked
myself is like how okay when we approach
a video and it's one of the reasons we
making less reactions just not that many
people out there who deserve to get
goofed on you know but it's like okay
how much does this person deserve to me
to be goofed on right now and I have to
measure our approach I just read it by
now in a way where I know they're gonna
see it so that's already in your head so
you you make it differently because
you're talking to a person and I know
there's a good chance we're gonna run
into them
in real life that's so we ran into that
happened to us with a few people's did
we ran into T we ran into actually both
of him thank you I first ran into T
Martin like three days after we dropped
that video how'd that go
you can't see me we like ran I [ __ ]
good right after we posted that video we
went down to Florida to meet dj khaled
right and what we're there we went to
Disney World or no Universal yeah and
[ __ ] who was there who we saw
wandering around Universal but team are
the Reid A's after and Florida we came
from New York I'm like what the [ __ ] it
might it blew my mind I saw him
immediately and I had a panic attack
cause he's like actually really big guy
right tall and lean and he [ __ ] kill
me I'm not sure how I would react if he
saw me but I was like either we gotta go
we jammed scared the [ __ ] out of me but
pretty recently
yeah they recently we run into Sandy
Kerry and addressing another party how'd
that go it was brutal it was brutal
I bet well he's you know the only person
I think in the entire world I would not
want to run into from it would be
probably Nicole Arbour and I'll tell you
something that no one I she's gonna
she's gonna find out I've mentioned her
name and she's gonna latch on to it and
how about how like I just know how she's
gonna react to this but here's why um
she made that VidCon last year I saw her
in Manhattan we said of the bar which
ranked hung out for an hour I I kept
trying to talk to her and she wasn't
really interested talk to me it was kind
of loud she's on the other side of the
table anyway she's talking to her
friends a little more I'm talking more
to Matt and I'm like I don't know it
doesn't really hit it off with her which
is weird I had it off most people okay
you know and but it's probably just just
sold out of there and we'd really get a
chance to talk so yeah there's a con
progressed as I see her and Matt all the
time she's all smiles he's all smiles I
love Matt and and then two weeks later
she goes home one makes dear fat people
two weeks later - and I like and so it
was very hard to not take it personal
huh because she had just spoken with me
in like one of the topics
Matt will talk about it often comes up
as people are interested I look like a
sideshow freak I mean people gonna
eventually talk about a little bit but
they don't want to know where I'm gonna
bring you know about uncomfortableness I
can't help but think I'd be a little
personal no probably wasn't she probably
doesn't think that way you're afraid
that she like it kind of person you
think in your mind she's like she met
you which one of them that inspired her
to make like one of those jokes in there
was about me might have been might have
been one but I stole yeah right and so
that would be the only reason like
anybody's evolved to have whatever part
you want to have you can say whatever
you want to say about fat people we
talked about a little bit before the
show like the fat people ate yeah well I
can do this thing I don't really care
doesn't really bother me even when they
send nasty [ __ ] to the peel box or to
our front doors stuff like that that's
really it's like that is just [ __ ] we
OH what what for example did you get so
there's this mean that my wife is
cheating on me with like some like
good-looking friend or like our friend
okay um but our friend asleep in a
monogamous long-lasting homosexual
relationship and so it's like so absurd
they would pick that guy as a guy that
my wife's cheating on me was not even a
right read of like and sick right
there's all this like stuff about how um
all this stuff about how like I can't
sexually satisfy a woman and here's the
thing I can't do to a woman like George
Clooney's gonna do okay but but here's
well none of us can be fair there are
things I'm pretty good at and you know I
haven't had a lot of complaints with me
and my wife seems to be very very quite
happy with it enough to where she
married me but so you know one time to
send like a dildo to the PIO box so
giant black dildo to satisfy my wife
with obviously I couldn't that's pretty
wild stuff like that and it's like I
don't know
that's pretty wild somebody I mean those
giant black dildos probably set you back
- yeah oh yeah I think is at least 40 50
bucks man that's a quality build oh yeah
and now it's just like we do I keep I
keep I kept if we ever need it right
there it's a weapon right
yeah it's a good I mean like that's the
thing that's the Internet you can have
whatever opinion you want to have and
sometimes I think that maybe he's done
like nasty still appeal box kind of
crosses line yeah I still take o it is
it still ticket job this is not like
threatening that that's at least it's
still a pure box yeah
peel box that's true right yeah well we
we get boxed like routine like every
three months for some reason and I never
link understand why they're like so
excited that I wore my addresses cuz
like I don't really care that you know
like what are you gonna do show up
you're gonna knock on the door or your
send some pizza in my house well I like
pizza sometimes I get a surprise Pizza
thanks you know could say well they want
none of the peace areas in the house
will deliver unless we prepay because I
was getting pranked so if you they just
pretty baby we had somebody link me to
the Tor network once and someone put out
to $3,500 in bitcoin to have someone
assassinate us and then on the same
night yeah somebody paid 3500 bucks had
an offer on the Tor network of 3500
backs to assassinate me and I don't know
why I mean this is crazy
right but they had the wrong address oh
wait how did you find out that someone's
trying to put a hit on you okay so
that's real it's not a joke I mean I did
nothing happened so I guess it was a
joke now yeah maybe the joke was on them
every said it somebody took their money
and laughed about it right but so I mean
it was all related to that police
station for unboxing it was like some
xbox kid who did it that's the craziest
part about it dude
okay if the Xbox Playstation people can
beef to the point I'm trying to
assassinate you then I have to say
there's no hope for humanity there is no
hope for the Middle East for our country
and they even have the money cuz right
you're saying 3,500 right like 3500
bucks in Piqua hey which would be now
worth like like fifty fifty thousand a
Bitcoin or something or maybe Ludacris
whoever took that money anyway so what
happened was we have a PlayStation 4
contacts us and like buggy we want to
give you a PlayStation 4 because of your
Frances we all thought was learners like
I love to take
on that but I'm I will be killed by that
no I still would have done it cuz it was
cool but Sid Schumann shows up my house
and he's got a Playstation and I'm like
so I get a film this unboxing is like
yeah and I can do it however I want to
he's like yeah and I think Sid maybe
took a personal day I didn't put them in
the video but I wanted it to be
realistic I wanted to seem like a real
Francis thing right so um it's not paid
Prohm or anything they're just give me
the damn thing you have yeah and so I
don't have to shoot anything I don't
have to do anything but I want to do
this because I knew people gonna love it
yeah and so I'm like let's pretend you
guys special delivered it you know not
by you said but just random ups or
whatever mm-hmm so we need a box so my
friends who are hanging out and one of
the meet said they go to their house and
get a box and we forget to blur out the
address so the address that gets leaked
the first time eventually get my address
right well the address that gets like
the first time is my my neighbor's my
friends address and so when they put the
assassination hit on tour Network they
sent it to my house then to show like
they sent an email to me hey man you
need to see this a sinister some crypt
courage some random person yeah and he's
like hey man you need to see this
probably the kid who set it up you click
on it
download ahead it downloaded the tor
browser figure out how to use it click
on the link finally click on the link
there it is there's the hit oh oh my god
oh my god that's not the right address
so I grabbed my phone I called my friend
Jason Jason you can have your house
there's a funny talking about that's
crazy
dingdong Jason what is happening right
now
someone's not the door don't eat right
don't answer the door and some friend
Jason one friend Ellis who lives at that
address they're like oh my god I don't
know they're hiding around the corner
who is it
Domino's they say that's what it is
that's and would say right they sent a
pizza so they're like can you step out
of the house to see if it's actually a
Domino's vehicle when I step out of the
house and there's the Domino's vehicle
with the sign on and I'm like do to
answer the door
it's my money answering the door we
don't want pizza
it's completely Buzard that he gets to
that level sometimes but it does but
like I you know I it's funny to me it
bothers me a little bit oh yeah that
would rather like watch Netflix and go
to sleep I mean it makes for good
stories you know that's that is that is
also one of the reasons I'm like maybe I
need to step Frances back a little bit
because maybe they're not trying to kill
me maybe they're trying to kill Franco
bread's do them the favor right you
should make a death Frances suicide
video where you like a Fight Club thing
my god I'll be so good I've always I did
the epic rap battle I'm sure sure you
haven't seen it but so finally push like
a pistol a million views which you you
wake up and score out in the morning but
um a little epic rap battle had got it
produced by my friend weevil from weevil
stuff you remember weevil stuff like Bob
do you know Badgers Badgers Badgers but
yeah that guy cool he's awesome a Zeke
rebel um but he produced a song for me
and I that was the very first time I
ever did like Boogie vs France this kind
of thing and try to keep it super meta
and I think eventually that storyline
will happen but I need to lose some
weight so I can move more and act more
me you saw me trying to get in here I'm
I'm falling apartment well you got a
dude thing yeah well get that surgery
and a surgeon's like I'm like so I could
lose how much from this I guess if you
don't try at all and you screw this up
maybe 150 pounds wow what you're like
just from nothing right just 300 so let
me ask on 300 I put me at 200 pounds you
think I can be under 200 that's like
that's where I am right it's like I
absolutely guarantee it I'm like so
you're talking about adding years to my
life and it goes Steve I'll be honest
with you I think we're adding decades
Wow like oh because I'm 43 that makes me
60 now that was good in one way I was
like man that's so I'm gonna get to live
forever I'm gonna spend more time with
my wife and oh my god round in 20 years
I'm gonna have to get a real job let me
ask you about this this surgery so how
is it they it's when they reduce the
size of your stomach right a lot of
people get confused cuz they think I'm
getting liposuction
right
which is not something the peace person
you get somebody your size might get
removed five or six pounds of stubborn
fat that won't leave a certain area or
like a you know a model might get that
done if they're having trouble getting a
certain shape to a certain area right
yeah that's a cosmetic surgery you
couldn't do that to me you can't take
300 pounds off of a body and expect it
to live right right yeah in a shotgun
and taking ten pounds off him you
wouldn't do anything right right so what
they do for me what they're doing for me
I'm getting the the gastric bypass where
they'll they'll sever 90% of my stomach
mmm just move it off to the side and
stay in a body but it just won't
actually be the only 10% of its current
size it'll be the size of a goalie so
basically when you eat you'll feel
really full right will fall off of a
symbol of I was working as a waitress
yeah and there was a couple sitting at
the table and they ordered one dish one
plate of fish and it had like a fish
fillet and like a side right and they
shared it and they both had they didn't
even weren't close to finishing it they
had like a little bite and then I was
like they were sitting there and I was
like are you guys done like are you
still eating and they're like no we're
full and I was like and they told me
they did that search Wow yeah so are you
uh I know that the risk of of losing
weight and happens with all of us is
gaining it back right is that something
to that your that works with this kind
of surgery or is this different I have
scoured YouTube trying to find the
answer to that question and I've also
done the studies and the reason I
decided to do the bypass the church
won't bypass over the sleeve is because
let's just sleeve the sleeve so with a
bypass they take 90% of the stomach they
move it off to the side they leave it
connected so the juices and stuff it
produces come down and I have a working
stomach of about 10% on sizing egg and
that gives us a she ation reset it gives
a reset on you know how I feel and how
satisfied the brain becomes it's a lot
of people realize there's like a little
second brain on the top yeah I've read
about that it's the stomach right that
tells you when to eat when not well yeah
I mean you feel a lot of emotions in
your stomach right yeah it's kind of
interesting so it uh that gets kind of a
reset
- then one of the coolest things they do
is they bypass a large part of the
intestines someone my size is overeating
their entire weight you that's part of
the same surgery part of the same
surgery they will then leave a good
chunk of the attest ins not like they
bypass it they don't take the remaining
something up from the bottom and bring
it up here so why would I when I do eat
food again I'll absorb less nutrients so
I have to eat nothing but super foods
what's the purpose of that um because I
have actually stretched my intestines
out so much or as you might eat some
food and get 8090 percent of the
calories I'm getting every calorie
because it sets in there for a really
long time so this is part of the effort
to lose weight right to get me back to
fairly unknown I just got it and so yes
if I really try at the year and a half
mark to start overeating again I could
probably within ten years get back to my
size you would you you could have to
really try but this stomach is capable
of stretching stretching out to the same
size as well and eventually I will have
my stomach right now they said it's
probably the size of a football I think
it's what he said a normal stomach would
be the size maybe a catcher's mitt are a
little smaller and and what I'll have is
an egg he said two things down the road
I'll probably have that normal size
catcher's mitt and then if I if I really
try to screw it up I put some real
effort into it then I could get back to
here but I have no intention yeah of
course but like the problem is a lot of
people think you know that's easy way
out number one there's more than
thousand chance on July 25th I won't
wake up how many was one in 1,000
there's a chance of surgical coma nuts I
feel like there's that percentage on I
almost any surgery it's 1,000 say it's
more dangerous eat your gallbladder
taken out oh [ __ ] but it's still an
optional surgery yeah for no good reason
did that's terrifying secondly yeah I'll
never be able to eat sugar again
I've called dump dumping syndrome so
it'll be a good six months to a year
that IFI ever eat sugar it will not
cause me to become violently ill both
front and back that helps with the diet
right and then I basically have to eat
super foods for the rest of my life
because I don't I will loose lean mass
so I have to target like 106 grams of
protein of the day but how do I do that
with a stomach that's yeah
Yeah right so I have to literally I just
because eating whey protein with a spoon
to be able to so it's a complete
overhaul and a lot of people think well
why not just lose the weight the normal
way and the answer is because of try it
over and over again but the statistics
show the numbers show that the majority
people that lose it get it back for some
surgeries intervention I think it's it's
it's worth saying to people because I
think a lot of people say why don't you
just lose weight why don't you just go
on a diet and exercise but I think at
this point and I mean you have like a
eating disorder right it's like OCD
thing it's not just you're not liking
most normal people who can just be like
well that's what I was gonna say earlier
it's the only thing that's really
important for you to understand somebody
gets 30 40 50 pounds overweight chances
are they don't have a lot of discipline
they don't they like food a lot right
yeah if somebody is maybe a hundred
pounds overweight 150 pounds overweight
they probably lack discipline and
education they probably don't really
understand right what they're doing and
why they're doing it wrong right I think
if you're getting 150 pounds or more
overweight there there's mental issues
there right now and I know what my
mental issues are in fact before I
qualified for the surgery I had to have
years and years of therapy to identify
why over eight how what causes it and
what led to this and stuff like that I
know exactly what my issues are a lot of
big people don't you know and that's
when you go back to my friend who I
mentioned he was on that weight-loss
show he'll tell you right now the reason
they put on the weight it's because I
didn't deal with a mental stuff first
and so when it came the check got hard
again hey and I have with YouTube has
done that for me right like the
beginning to meet you guys get it to be
on a show like this I don't this I'm
gonna carry this high for a long time at
high you can't do this ice cream can may
be as happy as I am today can to do this
right VidCon is is like heroin if-if-if
P food is aspirin I'm saying and so I've
got so much going on in my life between
the wife the dog the family all by
buying a house in the house in the home
I in the town I was homeless anything I
was homeless that's up for six weeks of
my life had nowhere to say nowhere to go
asleep into my roommates dorm room floor
that's breaking into buildings of the
campus sleeping on couches until I got
up first and last month's rent and that
saying we just bought my dream house I
don't I mean food is just a nuisance to
me now doesn't really do much I think
that it's really important to educate
people because like we were talking
before we went on air about fat people
hate this subreddit super controversial
subreddit that was like number one on
reddit for a long time for a long time
it was on the front page and reddit shut
it down for being a hate I hate
subreddit but I have like mixed feelings
as I said because on one hand people
need to understand that people of a
certain size have them have a eating
disorder right it's not just like oh I'm
lazy and I don't care and I just eat
because I'm fat like I think most people
have a certain size are painfully aware
right of and unhappy with their weight
and like you have to be compassionate
understand that the part that rubbed me
wrong about fat people hate or the thing
that I identified and thought was funny
about fat people a drink was like the
fat people fallacies right yeah they're
like yeah we're they're like I don't
know why I'm fat I ate I only had one
pint of ice cream this morning and
that's some like this shit's that
subreddit does still exist and I still
subscribe to today fat people logic I
hope that right that was it's funny
because that's kind of therapy to me I
read the time and I'm like that's you
know sometimes it's the again sometimes
it's just completely like no one's ever
actually thought that way but it's funny
to pretend that we do yeah occasionally
I see a little bit of myself in that but
I think like what you said education is
a lot of the problems heal like yeah
Ella's mom there her family's not fat
people at all by any means but she
she'll like deep fry vegetables and
there's like no health there's no
nutrition there at that point like this
just it's just oil and like the
semblance of some vegetables right here
there's nothing healthy there and I'll
be eating and I'm trying to have a lean
dinner she's like Ethan eat some
vegetables
she said that like you realize that
that's like not healthy right so I think
a lot of these old school people don't
understand right now you're that eating
a bowl full of oil and vegetables isn't
good for you I will tell you the
toughest debate ever have and like there
are people are gonna shut
down the stream when I say what I'm
about to say but this is juicy let's go
away it's not it's always okay
let me put it the right way it's always
calories and versus calories out it's
always that you always have to eat less
and move more it is always that that is
always well that's gonna have air so
that's science right but in some cases
specifically diabetics the math doesn't
always work out so ok expand on this so
um
insulin resistance makes it very
difficult to burn fat because insulin is
a big portion of burning fat this comes
right from my my or hormone Larry word
for work so when I lost 50 pounds while
diabetic mm-hmm and I'm disappointed by
it I'm like I can't believe only lost 50
pounds I I mean we did a liquid diet for
six weeks I brought in 1,800 calories a
day on a bad day I put in like 2,500
mathematically I should've lost closer
to 100 and it was a Steve you're
diabetic and I'm like what do you mean
he goes well your body's gonna choose to
burn lean fat lean meat before it burns
fat oh I'm like what and so we go
through the whole nine yards well you
know let's do the test well you have 275
pounds of lean mass and so your body
will choose to burn lean mass first
because of the insulin resistance and so
I have to burn through my muscles which
they and so it just gets complicated get
smother now we're still only talking
like a tennis 15-20 percent margin at
worst like somebody with a terrible
metabolic condition and all that stuff
it's the only a small margin I guess the
the faculty person logic is like that
one of the classic ones is like um I
have a slow metabolism right right what
you're talking about being a diabetic if
you're diabetic you could and if you're
not if you have a sedentary lifestyle
style and I put in $10 yeah it's a car
do you know in the data your body won't
move in the direction of fat-burning but
would have to prove to that it needs to
burn fat so you need at least 10 minutes
of cardio every day but to some extent I
always felt like I'm sure there's
something to that but it always doesn't
there's something that doesn't make
sense because it's like you exert a
certain amount of calories every day you
eat a certain amount of calories what
happening
in between right like what if you if you
eat mm and you and you burn 3000 like
there's not what's what's like the magic
figure where somehow your body's not
burning the calories that it should the
beats the living hell and me I dunno
like in the case of insulin-resistant
out producing the horn oh yeah how's the
body to burn fat I think in the case of
diabetes your body is is is is not it
doesn't have all the chemicals there or
does not respond to the chemicals
correctly to burn the fat first so
choose it's lean matter then I think it
probably still always keeps to the laws
of thermodynamics because you can't
break the laws of thermodynamics or to
death if they don't have the vitamins
coming in right if they I think if
they're taking I think it is entirely
possible for a morbidly a priest person
to starve to death while they're still
morbidly obese if they have the wrong
hormonal set in their body and the
markers are off and their body's not
doing what it's supposed to do
I think it'll eat enough lean mass first
oh wow instead of fat and then damn it
you know you know lean mass for talking
heart muscle we're talking muscle and
what what's a muscle your heart and so
you wake in your heart you'd have a
heart attack and starve to death because
of that you know I think that's entirely
possible if the chemical is wrong I
think that may not make sense like one
of the billion people that doesn't make
sense it's not my condition and if
someone's listening right now it's
probably not your condition either I'm
not giving you an excuse yeah you still
have to do the work you still have to
get with the nutritionist to figure out
what your personal body needs are you
still need to get with a trainer to
figure out what your exercise needs are
you need to get with a doctor who will
help you figure out your weight loss
patterns like that you still have to do
the work right there's no excuse to not
do the work yeah or you'll die yeah you
know and you'll die very unhappy and
very unhealthy that's the thing I can
tell you so let's just interesting no
it's fascinating I've always been really
fascinated by it I want to know let's
let's get back into it I'm gonna take a
quick break all right I'm gonna go to
the bathroom go get some more water and
plug in this laptop to die
okay so don't go away guys we will be
right back in two minutes
and if you leave you know tell me what's
gonna happen if they live Wow
what the hell that's not what's gonna
happen who am i killing I will cry you
looked at like bookie when you said that
Ethan will kill Y cheese that was dark
it's usually just like a little like
something Bad's gonna happen guys all
right I'm gonna kill boogie apparently
so way to go Harley's don't leave I
don't want to do that yeah there's like
at least one guys I'm slaying that close
button he's like all right we'll be
right back in a couple minutes
welcome back I staged a podcast I hired
with buggy and Gila
what up pimps yeah slam baby before we
are right before we went on the air you
were saying that you had this rape story
that got me oh I was talking about how
we do this show live and so I'm always
careful not to say something really dumb
Oh which happy it happens you know
you're doing it live you're gonna say
some really stupid [ __ ] and it already
happened to me once where George filthy
Frank was sitting on this couch behind
me and we were having a conversation
about rape and nature I don't know why I
don't usually talk about rape as a
subject of conversation but I said
something and George reacted behind me
like he was on camera and now I got
memed into oblivion and that video has
like a million views yeah so then you
volunteered I said that I was old and I
was writing my first sketch yeah my
first stand-up set but first 15 that's
mm the first hard 15 so I wanted to be a
stand-up comic did not realize I'm
standing up and it is actually involved
a little bit's bit yeah but um I wrote a
joke about a topic this private of me
I've talked about this very very briefly
but I had some inappropriate stuff
happen to me growing up well I'm so
sorry I feel like I think that it's okay
that I get to make this joke I think it
please do not kneel gaffney for making
this joke because this is how I process
my [ __ ] okay yeah see here's the joke
okay as someone who has been hurt that
way
I think rape is never funny I think rape
let me repeat
rape is never funny said a joking matter
and they can
you should be writing jokes about it
it's never funny except maybe one time
it could be funny and that's when you're
being raped by a clown but that's only
because you can honk his cute little
nose and when he keeps hitting me
Fetty I can't imagine anything more
horrifying to be raped by a clown
literally the most scary image I've ever
had in my life I'm not I'm not
traumatized by the joke I'm sure his
image would be raped my clown Christ I
drove I wrote that I stand by it today I
think it's completely tasteless I mean
that it can make a lot of people feel
very uncomfortable to even hear about
the topic and I understand that but I
think the joke itself is sound I don't
think it's a it's like fair enough all
right you're not gonna get triggered out
of a book you're not gonna have to
retire for telling that joke but I had
like this I had like that's the way I
deal with that's how I deal with like
bad stuff in my life and since I've had
more than my fair share of bad stuff I
have just a really messed up since I'll
tell you I'll tell you the day my brain
broke for the first time the day that I
officially became a bad person okay so
my grandmother had Alzheimer's disease I
loved her to death ultimately was her
name but this is back in the late 80s
and she was about five years advanced
and Alzheimer's and it moved pretty
quick first that was pretty pretty
pretty deep in and so we're about 75
miles away where we lived
we were down shopping and my mom stops
at a payphone she calls my grandfather
up her her dad and her mom and says uh
hey Dad Carl is today a good day to
visit how's mommy and she says well
she's doing real good she's real bright
real clear if you want to come up not be
a good time well great I mean I think me
and my sister and my brother are all in
the car so we pack up we drive that 75
miles there through mountain hills the
second hour and a half two hours to get
there
and when we get there between that phone
call and when we arrived all hell had
broken loose
my grandmother had it in her head that
my grandfather was trying to kill her
like that's just how her Alzheimer's
presented and so because of that they'd
already like to removed all the weapons
and guns and knives from the house
so all the roses like butter knives and
forks and something that had been going
on for a while for a while that's [ __ ]
so so Alzheimer's is a cruel cruel
there's gonna be one of the worse things
absolutely right but she dad Carl got
her you know got her out of her tonight
coat got her underwear on or got her
brawl on her and starts to put her
pearls on her shows wore pearls started
get her pearls on her and she got into
her head that he was trying to choke her
so she decided to bury the knives in the
house get him away from him so he
couldn't stab her so all there's left in
the house is butter knives right and so
she rushes out in the front of the house
in the garden and she's like digging a
hole to bury these knives and it's
pouring rain and at that exact moment we
pull up in the car and so here's my
grandmother enter bloomers covered in
mud rain pouring down on her trying to
bury butter knives in the garden my
grandfather screamin ultime get your
house get your ass in the house you're
gonna die of a cold you're crazy
y'all call you try to kill me and my
brain said either you're gonna listen to
my Chemical Romance every day for the
rest of your life or this is funny
so which one are you gonna choose well I
chose funny I I mean how do you not and
so I started laughing and my mother
who's is my mother who's abusive she
turns around she goes with them he's so
funny
Stevie J I have to tell us and well
maybe she'll grow buttercups [ __ ] oh my
god right because this my god well my
mom be cautious but here's the thing
there's two things you know I feel like
I always laugh in those situations too
and it reminds me like my favorite
author and someone who's had a huge
effect on me is Kurt Vonnegut I don't
know oh that is yeah and he was writing
him in his autobiography that that guy's
been through some [ __ ] in his life I
mean he's passed now but he's seen some
of the worst things and he he writes
this really dark comedy and he said like
whenever confronted with death or
tragedy he always laughed it's just like
something he felt inside of him just a
lot that's how he dealt with it right
and his family members used to get super
frustrated and be like the why are you
laugh
I got his mom's funeral who he loved he
was like laughing and they're like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you like I'm
obviously morning it's not it's not
funny per se but right I
no you have two choices that is the
reaction Kurt Vonnegut actually is the
it was Kurt Vonnegut and Douglas Adams
that push me towards I'm not I would not
really say that I'm a nihilist but I
would say I have very nihilistic
tendencies and I think I've embraced the
absurdity of this whole thing I think
it's one of the reasons I was able to
eat myself to an absurd level it's
because I have one point I genuinely
understand that none of this matters
right yeah so like you know they tell me
hey the way you're eating you know you
know 25a the way you're eating you'll be
dead by thirty I was like oh well that's
something I'd like to happen I'm
miserable so I get to die and also eat
all the food I want well that's a long
day ray do you think like depression had
a lot or had a hand in oh absolutely I
sit right up and like the the the being
poor as well like when we were homeless
when we got our first month's and last
month's rent together we got our first
place we would go to the C C's piece of
buffet and spend five bucks and we would
sat down for lunch and we leave after
dinner and one time we're eating that
day I'm like how do you think you idiot
in that day to 3,000 3,000 4,000 5,000
easy just like that's it because I
didn't know if I was eating tomorrow cuz
I don't know if it's yeah right um and
so it actually got to the point like the
manager of the Fayetteville C C's knew
us by name and one day just walked over
and he's like hey let's turn off still
and I'm like I knew this day was coming
I'm so sorry that we do this no no it's
fine dude
you guys are always playing with those
carts what are those cards I was playing
Matt to the gathering magically passed
the time and he we talked it cuz you
guys sure render awhile you guys not
have anywhere to go and we told him the
situation nice and he's he's like well
son you don't have to worry about
costing me money says you know what my
food cost is hmm I said what because
that pizza you guys special order the
barbecue one do you know how much I pay
for that about 23 cents
oh my god so you'd have to eat ten of
those before it even start to affect my
bottom line and I'm like oh okay
well he got to where he recognizes we're
coming in because hey those two guys get
drinks today no they get sodas hey those
guys already paid earlier like it's like
one of the nicest guys it's Christian
and like openly Christian about it but
not like the appetizing whatever is
there like one of those people that like
lived the life lived like exactly the
life that he was
live wow that's a good book you know I
was really impressed with but that that
led to this like pattern of just eating
as much as I could whenever I could
because so it's a lot of stuff combined
it sounds like it's a whole host am i I
am a number I did a number on myself and
a lot of people got a number on me
beforehand and so I got to be like
straight-up crazy like this straight up
like kind of I shouldn't be able to
function but I managed to somehow got a
crazy it's exciting at six I was
watching your I was watching some of
your old videos about like did your back
store with your family and that [ __ ] was
really really heavy-duty I mean for the
people who don't want to have to go
through that I don't want to depress you
too much but like I read books like
flowers of Algernon and they read to
like a you know documentary to me
Jesus great like it's just it's it was
just as messed up as it could be right
you know I mean any way that a person
could be abused I was abused and that
was on a daily basis it's not a weekly
not a monthly basis a daily basis I just
you know what was the deal with your mom
cuz I remember hearing about it and that
she was real abusive Tuesday I'm very
angry she was dichotomous and and like
that's one of the reasons I think that's
common with all these kind of my
characters like the more broken a person
is the more attracted I am to that
person a lot of the times just like I
get straight-up befriend the most
dangerous messed up people and it's
because I try to find the good in those
people and there is right and they're
almost right um and so that's like why
whenever someone who's notorious on
YouTube like a daddy alive situation
yeah the very first thing I did was I
heard that story I wrote daddy ngo5 on
Twitter I'm like can we talk and my goal
there wasn't to help him or protect him
my goal was to get involved to try to
like get an advocate into the home and
he's like boogie they're gonna take away
my youtube channel sin like worse than
that probably dude but you know a good
way to save face and a good way to maybe
keep your YouTube channel would be to
get an advocate in the home today
contact social services in advance and
then get your own therapist today I know
you've got the money we've talked about
money so get the therapist in advance
get them into the home and film them in
the home film a therapy session show
that to the world
they are actively making an effort right
show the social service woman visiting
let them know you're actively making an
effort
and he's thinking always trying to help
me with P or no I'm trying to help the
kids I know when the kids I know when
the person comes in they're gonna see
what's going on and then something's
going to happen I'm just trying to
convince him that get somebody into the
home it might it might save your YouTube
channel right that's that's the only
path to victory anyway that situation
was so [ __ ] but like I tried that's
what I try to do I try to get in I try
to get into you know because when I was
raised by monsters so whatever a monster
raised her head I'm I can't open I just
shove myself right in there and did you
were you able to like talk to him was he
he was receptive to a certain point but
he kept saying boogie the videos are
fake boogie the videos are fair and I'm
like all right believe that by the way
it doesn't matter I think that part
that's a good point too but I think that
part of it was scripted right so I think
that him and his maybe like let's talk
about the Incas yes this isn't personal
insight this isn't something he said to
me this is entirely alleged please do
not sue me this is my theory okay but I
personally feel like for the parents it
was definitely scripted they don't write
this my impression of horse not want to
do oh yeah right I think maybe that's it
I think the kid is used to getting
pranked and getting rewarded after the
prank mm-hmm what I think when I look at
that video having a severe anxiety
disorder myself when I look at that kid
it's clear that is exhibiting extreme
anxiety absolutely right I see myself in
that kid so even if he was in on it on
some level he still cannot process it
and he's a kid it doesn't know it you
can't tell anyway like is is growing in
this environment that's so weird like
they're pranking him his parents are
pranking it's very sober and they're
making videos and like what's even a
reality and what's also like their
living is from [ __ ] over there kids
it's like what kind of a weird-ass
reinforcement yeah that whole situation
was so [ __ ] up and like it ended up
with them losing their kids I don't know
if that's ever happened on YouTube where
people lost their kids it's the new well
they lost two of the three right Dave
I think they have the older kit still oh
that's good they loved him anyway right
which is like that's another one that I
like that it's insane and I hate to say
it but literally they were treated like
redheaded stepchildren like that's an
old I'm never seen like that's literally
the cliche and it happened that still
can't believe it but that's the thing I
think like what little expertise I have
with being abused and then has spent a
lifetime of therapy and group therapy
because of it mm-hmm I feel like that
was another lack of education situation
right like I think maybe he did not
fully understand what was appropriate
and what wasn't appropriate
I mean maybe doesn't even have the
capacity to fully like to have pick that
up on himself if that's the situation
where I felt like it needed intervention
right I don't think he was truly the
mean spirited I think what he was I
thought I think he personally thought it
was acceptable and no one have ever
educated him otherwise that's what I
think I mean it's possible he came from
a [ __ ] up family and that was just the
norm and then all of a sudden you're
putting on the internet and everyone's
like dude that's not normal right excite
at home maybe that's normal and where he
came from that's normal and that's
tennis and I'll tell you and that's one
of the most fascinating things about
growing up abused because to this day to
this day sometimes I'll remember
something that happened and I'll think
that's not how other people experience
life that's an idle happens that's still
to this day to even three weeks ago do
you remember like one of the most recent
one the most reason when I looked at my
wife and boy did you ever sleep with
your mom like sexually but in the same
bat oh and she's like yeah I like when I
was like four or five and I like I'd get
really scared and I'm like yeah but I
was I liked it everyday thing or
whatever and she's like no like so if I
slept with my mom when I was 12 still
mm-hmm that would be weird right and
she's like yeah so if I didn't have my
own room at the age of 12 like that's
weird
right yeah yeah and she's like yeah no
that's that's very unusual Steve yeah
and I'm like so why when I moved out of
my mom's bed and not having a bed and
her refusing to get me one then that's
way [ __ ] up right oh yeah it did I
guess I've just never really thought
about other
sleeping arrangements I've seen it on
television and I guess I kind of always
knew that wasn't right but I didn't
realize how not right it was yes it is
yeah with like when you're abused as a
kid you at the time it may seem like a
game or something so I think that you
have no concept you're good yeah yeah
which is like you know I mean I've
always I've always done okay with girls
which is I know that's surprising
you know anybody listening but I've
always done all right with girls and so
one of the very first things I had
always opened with it's like first date
material for me to like and I'm not
interested in kids and they're like why
I'm like oh because I come from an
abusive home and I'm afraid that I'd be
abusive to kids so I won't risk it and
they're like well but you don't seem
abusive wrong like and I'm not I'm 100%
sure I'm not but it's not worth the risk
is screwing up another person's life so
I'm not interested it's mm-hmm well
that's a hell of a deal-breaker for me
sorry you want to get that out there and
blow it away right like I just like
straight off the bat like hey I come
from an abusive home my scale of what's
right wrong may not be perfect you want
to get that out there and I don't ever
have kids because I don't know that I
can race have you ever had him really
don't think that I don't think so now I
think really the work that we've done in
the last four or five years especially
the work that I've done since I met my
wife and with my wife specifically I
think that we've grown into a place
where and especially because I trust her
so incredibly much and she's so good
handling me like you know we always the
joke about you're his hair I mean she
genuinely is my hair like I can't
function I literally can't function yeah
I could not get through VidCon because
I'm paralysed with anxiety and so Steve
we need to be here in 20 minutes do you
have this here in a few minutes Steve
it's time to take your medicine it's
time to eat I literally cannot function
without her that's pretty dark that
you're afraid of abusing kids like
obviously you I could say from knowing
you that you wouldn't do that but just
like the fact that that's so deep-seated
in your mind is really so [ __ ] up
right well I'll tell you and it's
interesting because it was visiting all
I have a brother and I have a sister and
my brother got less of it than I did by
quite a bit my sister got way more of it
but in a shorter period of time than I
did I was there the full eight ten years
my brother was there for 17 and but he
had my dad to protect him yeah
before my dad got sick I had enough
taken care of my dad and then my sister
she got the just the worst like great
like stories you wouldn't believe maybe
one day older younger she's older
they're both older I'm just worried that
it like people be solutely I'm not
buying that because that is [ __ ]
depressing
but but like she she she might hear this
you know so I don't really want to speak
her business but like you imagine it and
whatever you're imagining right now that
that happened but worse like whatever
you're thinking and she just got the
worst of it she's young so she ended up
running away with your parents or she
got it from both was also be Civ well to
her she's got the special Yeah right
yeah forgot that she got the double
whammy there yeah we talked occasionally
it's it's very broken when we do because
there's a lot of history there and
there's a lot of mess stuff up there but
we touch base a couple times a year and
she's yeah I love her but she's very
different because of what she went
through
and it's hard it's hard you know I think
I've recovered in I think she's
recovered as much as I have but in a
very different way hmm you know she kind
of went into like a subculture and she's
just part of that subculture and you
know I went into like I don't know kind
of like my brother once said to me
something real [ __ ] I grow up with accent
I sounded like hey y'all how y'all doing
today very interest I still go into it
my wife is like freaked out by just why
are you doing a voice right well honey
I'm just scared shitless and yeah but
she my brother comes home one day in
because if you ever want to be taken
serious in this world you got to lose
the accent really because he went to
Romania Tech and his first year they
ridiculed him for having a deep
Appalachian accent and she's like it's a
wonderful beautiful accent so glad when
I go back home I go right back into it
and like I'm there for 20 minutes and
I'm a newbie and it just for like come
oh yeah the next I'll go to I'll go to
the Apple he's never like um hey honey
what do you want most well have y'all
got Mountain Dew I sure let it drink me
one of them and I'd say what
love me some appetizers now y'all got
wings now they heart honey because I
can't handle a hot one
no I can handle mild you got my own all
right well let's get some information
that I'm only like half Appalachian if
you really get in the mountains right
straight from king of the hill but I
tried to move into he said listen to the
news and talk the way to do in those so
I started practicing and that's how I
got into all the voices to self and
that's like even the Frances voices from
back there and I found I could do hi ho
there this is Kermit D for all accurate
or do not there is no try
judge me by my size do you you should
not write I started doing all these
stupid terrible accidents and voices and
you know it's so funny I had a tape
recorder and I would record this stuff
and I would play it back for myself and
then I'd be like mom listen I'll take it
to the school
hey Dustin listen it's okay I don't
really I really think it's a funny man
okay I wanted someone to listen to what
I was creating so bad and kids today
I mean I've watched probably 150 spinner
cringe compilations because they could
turn on the camera at any second right
and there are meet legal live they can
broadcast the world is probably the
worst thing about being a kid today how
painfully and permanently you can
embarrass right and it's not it's not
when you'll make a mistake it's it's not
if I win
if I had access to camera as a kid no
wars would want me but you know oh I
know for a fact that I would never say
it but I would have definitely well I
grew up on Sam Kinison stuff and so I
grew up I'm like you know just all this
like super offensive humor and so when I
was alright
my original comedy sketches were just
like oh like Jark dart right right I
guess I can only imagine I can only
imagine I want to ask you about your
anxiety because that's something I've
had a lot of oh yeah trouble with in my
life I remember I was used to be really
debilitated by anxiety
I went before I went off to college I
was getting like super severe panic
attacks and like I mean
oh yeah like depersonalized and just
like super fuzzy brained and just like
so out of it for like the whole time of
my college it was really hard for me to
feel like I could be myself right up
until I mean I still have trouble with
it frankly but up until only the past
like five years even did things start to
like normalize to the point where I felt
like I could have a normal life right
like it's an awesome man I'm so glad to
hear they I didn't know is that bad for
you but I've only only ever known you in
recovery you don't I'm saying and your
recovery has been so brilliant and so
incredible and now to hear that it's
it's almost hard to believe to be free
thanks dude I mean there were it was
really dark times am I like before I
started when I was smoking weed in high
school right before I left for college
yeah and I started getting panic attacks
and I would feel like cuz I used to be
like really confident and kind of I felt
like I was sharp and confident guy and
when I whenever I smoked weed I would
get in my head and I'd feel like really
insecure and really like just not myself
and I kept smoking and smoking smoking
as well my friends were doing at the
time and I just wanted to hang with them
and it got to this point right just like
hated myself but I didn't realize I
didn't like fully understand it so I
just like snapped one day so hard and I
went from feeling like super in control
and confident
- just like total mental collapse and I
don't think I slept for like two weeks I
I didn't understand what's happening I
thought I was going like schizophrenic
and it got to the point where I wasn't
sleeping and then I was actually like
hallucinating because I wasn't sleeping
I was like oh [ __ ] I'm I was rehearsing
in my mind like telling my parents I was
going schizophrenic as it felt so real
and summers I didn't tell anyone about
it - which was probably the hardest part
yeah
experiencing that feel like talking
about it was at the beginning of
recovering it of course but I'm always
says for anybody else think it always is
yeah ever the problem you see very right
now it Kara pissed or a fan or friendly
or a reddit subreddit or our group
therapy or a forum in all the starts of
sharing it
you literally cannot because and I think
what people don't realize is the the
pivotal part of sharing stuff like that
is its twofold
the first is hearing from somebody else
their experiences or their vision of you
know or something like that can be very
healing
more importantly it's organizing your
thoughts you need some outside influence
because in your mind should just get
buddy worse and worse even when you sit
down you walk into alcohol Alcoholics
Anonymous for example and they make you
introduce yourself and you talk about
your stuff even just that three minutes
it forces you to gather everything in
your brain all these loose threads that
are flowing around and to put it into
that three-minute speech and then you
have a better understanding of yourself
exist so it all starts to talking it
really does I'm sorry to interrupt no no
it's such an important I agree so much
like I held it in for two weeks or three
weeks and that's it made it way way
worse and I think I was just embarrassed
I was embarrassed and I felt like weak
and I think that's the only reason why I
didn't talk about it so I don't know you
just have to find someone to hear you
out on it yeah
is that what is that what it's like for
you I mean listen what's your anxiety
more like it's I don't know I'm still
learning what's my excited because I'm
having problems like all the time ours
is different yeah it's different
I have not self diagnosed very important
clinically diagnosed post-traumatic
stress see that's some [ __ ] yeah right
and so I have social anxiety again
clinically diagnosed social anxiety but
I learned overcome that through exposure
therapy right so just get out there and
just force myself to do it
yeah and I'm still miserable the whole
time I'm doing how does it manifest
itself and you're like when you say
you're anxious what are you feeling the
most common for me is a disassociative
state so I will kind of hit eject on the
brain and that's what I get and it's a
[ __ ] worse well it's hate it it's
actually a tool I've been taught it's
actually a tool that I my body used so
the very first time I ever disassociated
was the very first time I ever got a
near-death beating
and so my mom just just wailed on me for
a long time and my body hit the eject
tool to say hey you know what this isn't
happening we're not here this is not
real nothing's here and so for me the
way I described it to try to get people
to understand it it's kind of like
trying to control a video game character
mm-hmm
through a broken television that's in an
aquarium mm-hmm that's across the room
on another planet depending on how this
associative I am right there how far
away I am from my own body but it feels
very much like the matrix to me I think
that's one of the easiest ways to I feel
like I'm jacked into this life and into
this body that's you know and so what
does that mean though that you just
don't like you don't care about stuff
you don't well I mean you may feel like
you're watching a movie or something I
feel like that is not a bad description
but I do still very much care right um
but I think people like people who have
disassociative States those are the
people that you know snap one day and
like murder somebody I'll never do that
right but like how do you account for
that because I'm just trying to like
conceptualize the thing I think I have
something different now that I hear you
just write it I I don't really sure I
well that's very separate too by the
PTSD that's a symptom of the poster
miraculous so when we talk about
post-traumatic stress what happens there
is a circumstance will happen in the
room that I'm in and that circumstance
will trigger hate using that word it's
mostly cause of you you can say you get
the head but not like triggering me like
oh I'm very offended in the act but
actually college they cause a chemical
reaction in my brain right that then my
brain believes that the thing that
happened to me then is happening again
now and so it'll trigger fight-or-flight
and it will begin to use all the tools
that it used to protect itself the first
time and what I perceive as reality is
no longer reality it will create that
moment in my brain again and so my brain
is like hey this is happening to you
again whatever terrible thing it is that
I'm remembering and then I'm
experiencing it and then I'll still have
a very cognizant awareness that the I am
here and then
is just a safe place and everything's
fine and so I have to fight my brain -
calm down - relax itself to handle
things concentrate on my breathing play
with my fidget spin or whatever
mostly realistically I serve social
media I try to distract myself I carry
three DS with me all the time I carry my
switch with me most of the time now
those are great distraction tools and
then just get processed all the
chemicals in my brain until they're gone
and so that's the real two ways that's
in the will the real two ways that I
really and then that this associative
state will kick in sometimes so the PTSD
does and then that's just awesome
because I just kind of sit there and
just we like it in a way it can be very
useful yeah can be very pristine so my
thing that I get it's called like it's
like a brain fart like depersonalization
I think it's called yeah where it's like
um it's almost like a bad high I get
like brain fogged and I don't feel like
myself I would say that's like level one
of what I've experienced a say like I'd
say I'd say that's like the how I spend
90% of my time
the worst is like because if I get that
feeling like before I come on this show
I get like super in my head or like
before I have to make a video over after
work and I'm like I can't do it cuz I
feel like I'm not funny I'm in my head I
feel like I'm just high and I'm like
paranoid I'm super sensitive to
everything and I just feel like I can't
perform I can't be myself and that that
to me is the scariest
worst part is that I can't be me you
know know that truth that should [ __ ]
me up
well what again through therapy what I
learned to do is I learned to basically
try to not create a persona because that
leads people to believe I'm disingenuous
and I am genuine to try to figure out
who and what I am who I want to be
specifically and then to push through
the anxiety and to push through the the
fog there and and project that person
right and so like who are you see like
really because here's the thing you're
not a body you're not a dis associate of
mine you're
you're not a victim you're person you
have personality of quirks you have
wants feelings desires figure out who
you are and then we're gonna learn how
to project that through the [ __ ] and
that's what we did that's how am i
though out of all the therapy I'm with
her and I must've been through 20 years
of it maybe 2 years of it was good and
that's real that's really frustrating
because a lot of people go I went to
therapy and it doesn't work and it
doesn't most of the time but it's all
like little small pebbles right yeah you
know therapy is in Iraq therapy is a
bunch of grains of sand every day every
session every whatever it adds up after
a lifetime right I know for me that's
how it worked a time but yeah that that
that was one of the best things in the
world so Heights into the one of the
reasons I think I'm so good at
performing and why I'm good at
performing the Francis character without
taking a break that ever having a break
is I learned how to project that
personality and that kind of wood
enacted us but at least people think
that I'm Jin Diane disingenuous and
maybe I'm someone that is true because
if I were genuine I would be comatose
most of the time does not speaking right
but this is who I want to be yeah so
even even tonight when I've got nervous
I'm just like I just gotta be me
I just gotta just let me be me yeah and
just let everything so it's true a lot
of the fear I have is like this
self-aware fear where I'm like oh my god
I'm gonna I'm not me right now instead
of just like being just accepting that
you don't feel good and just being like
okay well I don't feel like myself
there's an and then like the panic sets
in and that freaks me out right just
being like okay I don't feel good don't
think about it just go with it
that kind of solves half the problem
right I will tell you a secret actually
so I live stream on Twitch yeah and one
of the reasons I went to live stream on
Twitch was to practice exposure therapy
for my anxiety that's the very first
time I went live
I lost my mind with exactly I was
terrified oh my god there's like 15
people watching and they're judging me
right now my god and it just like
correct me a little bit and so I would
stream on YouTube a little bit but it's
hard for me to find an audience on the
YouTube channel for some reason and I
really wanted the game and when I
started to move to twitch it was when
gaming still was not yet so I can sign
up for an MCN took like 30 percent of
your income and so I will twitch
let me do it without any problem they'll
pay me to do it instead of me paying
somebody else for the right to play
games so I'll do that and so twitch
became this like therapy thing for me
and sometimes I will have a nervous
breakdown I will cry in the bathroom
floor for 20 minutes and then get up and
walk in and stream and if you ever watch
my stream the nights that I'm playing bo
burnham music it generally is me
psyching myself up prior to the show
playing bo burnham to just get ready to
do it if you hear the Kanye rant it's
because I'm psyching myself up to do it
oh and that's a great attitude but it's
like that's super important like I think
a lot of people struggle with anxiety
and depression in like my what I would
say to them and I think there's really
only one answer is like you just you
can't give in to it
you can't just lay in bed right and just
wait to die you have to [ __ ] push
yourself out of bed and that's your
thing that's true of literally whatever
problem you have right kind of like I
think when I think of like Ricky baroque
you don't Ricky from yea Twitter right
oh yeah like Ricky could easily be a
victim for what's going on this corner
feeling miserable for himself
yeah right but he's taken what his life
has handed him and not only just
accepted it but embraced it and it
turned negative into a positive yeah and
just and it's heaven as far as I can
tell
having an incredible time doing it yeah
and I love every second of it he loves
every second of it and I think that's
somebody who could veer very easily been
paralyzed by the fear paralyzed by the
things that hold him back yeah and I
think that's all life is right like I
was a shut-in for seven years and you
know what I got out of that I lost seven
years yeah I can get anything out of
that right I didn't get I didn't heal I
didn't get better I didn't feel better
nothing nice happened to me during that
period I said man I just played a budget
I requested Oh ever question we need the
bun and every what sir
no wonder you lost seven hundred years
of your life [ __ ] what was it was uh no
I played so hard I lost my entire
childhood ever cries dude what was the
name it was a PvP I want to give a
shout-out to the Praxis server I want to
give a shout-out to a with rocks Praxis
PR e ex-us remember all the servers were
named after the Gothic or some [ __ ] I
don't remember Alan Zachary on
Valentine's AK yep
Valens acteam P
yeah Wow did I was on that too big of a
[ __ ] to play it was a play on a pvp
server yeah dov'è never quest and did
not come out for seven years
oh I had to go from EverQuest to world
of warcraft but then because I mean
every question last so when did you come
out of the this shell was it during the
well age uh in 2005 just I realize I had
not had sex with another person so seven
years and that was the Kali and I had
the last girl I'd had sex with we were
together
off and on for like six and a half years
and she was getting married and I'm like
you know what I don't know if that's why
I've been harboring all of this [ __ ] or
not but here's the thing I don't want to
die alone and I looked around I'm like
how alone am i I have a roommate and
we're friends and I've burnt every other
friend bridge I had so I'm gonna make
one of them myspace account so here's so
much and I put myself out there and I
met a few girls through there I went on
a few first dates but they go pretty
badly you know when you're like hey so
here's the thing I don't have kids
because I'm afraid of might punch them
not a bit of a turn-on but I've met a
girl out of like Memphis Tennessee and
my brother had a place in Memphis
it has a reason his family down there so
I packed up one day to stay a weekend
with my brother and met the girl and
she's like you want to go to downtown
Memphis and I'm like absolutely not that
sounds like a horrifying experience we
should go and like we wrote the duck
boat and I'm like I this is so much
better than what I've been doing over
the last seven years it's so much better
than just on your waiting tonight so
even though I'm terrified and even
though this is painful
because I do not fit on the duck boats
those are tiny little [ __ ] seats um I
was just glad I did it and so that was
the beginning half of the whole thing
well we in her data for a while and I
she was my excuse to get out of the
house for a while and I ended up we
ended up breaking up and I ended up
playing Magic the Gathering again went
back to that game got me into my local
gaming store every Friday night and then
I started judging magic tournaments and
magics like the good version of
EverQuest well it takes you out of the
house right yeah exactly to interact
with people in the world
spend like $100 on a single piece of
paper okay yeah the dream yeah but well
but you know I I mean we started going
back to pro tours and stuff from first
row qualifiers and and really like the
Grand Prix's and I was like man why
don't why ever stop doing this I wish
I'd played magic I never learned how to
play that game it's a great game it's
expensive and sometimes it has its ups
and it's downs I played it now for 24 25
years since 1994 I came in at January of
94 Wow so I played it it's probably at
least once a week what is it what is it
about the game that you love so much is
it like I did super strategic that's
exactly it's like like I don't know when
you build a deck it's like very personal
you've chosen to build if you're playing
commander like the commander you choose
or the are this the standard deck that
you're playing or whatever and then
there's a social aspect every good
person I've met other than like maybe 1
or 2 people I've been over a game of
magic the person who kept me from
literally being homeless the guy gave me
the dorm room to sleep on and becoming
one of my best friends who lives with me
and my wife still to this day he known
for 20-some years I met him over game of
magic Wow and I mean III mean everybody
that we have 20 25 people come over to
my house on Saturday night and they've
all been hand-picked people you know
sometimes they're plus ones but for the
most part they're all been hand-picked
people that I picked over a game of
magic and that's me one person that
tries out a little group interesting
yeah and the game is really fun too but
I mean that's when somebody who asked me
every once well how does an adult make
friends I'm like you have a local gaming
store in your town because if you do
show up right and pick a game maybe
magic that's probably most popular in
there but pick a game and play with
people you think generally magic players
are more like are welcoming and warm
people it depends on your community our
community was always super cool but a
lot of that has to do the fact that I
live in Northwest Arkansas
it was just absurdly progressive and one
of my favorite stories about how
progressive Northwest Arkansas is and
it's not like in an obnoxious way it's
not like we're talking like people
rioting on campus kind of way it's just
everybody just kind of well okay so
let's talk about progressivism for just
a second how can we do this yeah of
course so I grew up in the 80s and 90s
right and so progressive in these 90s
was all about tolerance it was all about
tolerating other people right like
there's there's Muslim
your neighborhood you should probably
just be okay with that yes focused on
just learning to be okay with that
and your your son might be a homosexual
and you just need to learn to focus on
being okay oh that okay you don't have
to like champion them you don't have to
do anything else just just accept that
and also hey if you happen to be gay or
a happening Muslim and you live in an
area area with bigots you got to
tolerate bigots because there are people
too right and like that was just the
whole kind of premise of how I grew up
and so Northwest Arkansas is still kind
of just lets people be people right and
so if you've got unlike the the drinking
strip in my town it's a law bar sports
bar gay bar a sports bar you know the
the the the transsexual bar that has the
the drag shows chicken wings right you
know and like right just does her thing
nobody really cares right and so like
when we had a pride parade in
Fayetteville about a year and a half ago
my friend Olivia who's trans she marched
it and my wife got this beautiful
picture she tweeted out on social media
and it's a protester and the protesters
wearing like a shirt like you know
protesting that although the whole gay
rights thing and Olivia says can I hug
you and he goes well of course you can
hug me why wouldn't I want to give you a
hug I I just don't you to go to hell I'm
worried about burning in hell that right
we don't have any personal problems
right it's just my book says that you
will burn in hell and I don't want that
to happen do you actually care it's a
care comes rightly so compassion right
that's where we don't have a lot we have
like maybe like one hate preacher
everyone but like I don't know it's a
great area so also our magic community
has just always been like very hey let's
just concentrate on the game you're
Republican I'm a Democrat you're black
I'm white I'm fat you're skinny who
cares this games fun do you like this
game sure you're gonna have dinner after
this yeah let's have dinner that's cool
so play some more there um it's not
always that way you know especially a
hard time imagining a Magic the
Gathering community being like a bunch
of like dicks I don't know why I just
met does it makes it like well every
once in a while you get to try hearts
right yeah I can't believe I lost your
yeah it's there's a minim screw and you
get the guy who's just kind of like I
know everyone someone you get that guy
who's very about his thing right
I'm very Republican I'm very Democrat
I'm very progressive I'm very bigoted
writer that guy like it supersedes the
game but then that's just like a
personal problem that has nothing that
game yeah that's just a guy who's like
who's really too deep into identity
point you when you come together for a
magic like you do tournaments like
gather drinks yeah like people right
like our local store the one I go to is
like gear in Fayetteville and they do
they'd like two or three events a week
so how many do then it depends that
could be as small as eight and I think
like for their pre-releases way they'll
get like 120 Wow and it's rice that
store like 100 some people but you're
saying yeah and then like if you go to
like a grand prix like Grand Prix Las
Vegas just took place yeah and I don't
want to guess a number here because I
don't want to be that off we're talking
tens of thousands of races a huge
tournament like you're we're talking
there massive massive massive confit
yeah like massive enormous what is the
entry flavor last grand-prix I played
and I play like 80 bucks I'm sure it's
more expensive these days
80 bucks so what does the first place
take home on something like tens of
thousands damn so is their professional
Magic the Gathering players allow and
they're people professionals people
streaming professionally there's people
go in the circuit who also streamer
freshly there's people like there's one
guy who's who's a trust well he ended up
putting money into like some sort of
stock broker thing and that stocks for
other people and like so he's rich but
he just likes the game so yeah it shows
up and it takes other people's money and
laughs about it now didn't care about
that and like there's it's just like any
other eSport there's a lot of
personalities doing the things that they
do in their their heroes sometimes and
they're villains other times and and
then everybody pictures about the state
of the game and it's fun to just
complain about you soon yeah and I I
hate eSports but matches the one I can
kind of tolerate like I want to hear
about the deck you played I want to hear
about him right I don't ever like what
decks one Oh what card they ban the Pro
Tour what card spiked that's interesting
usually yeah I know I usually this is a
weird tradition we always ask about
ghost stories I have a ghost or a I want
to take another quick break
I I don't think I think we have to end
after that because I have the thing oh
we have to wrap it up okay we have to
okay so let's end on the classic spooks
and goofs this is the most random thing
menial or super skeptical people we
don't really believe in ghosts but
somehow everyone we've had on the show
has like really fascinating supernatural
/ ghost stories so we always throw it to
the guess what we've got English books
and gives her no weird about this you
also don't have to I do I do and okay so
I grew up dabbling in variety of
Christian religions my mom would expose
my new as many as she could a Christian
religion Christian religious like all
the different Hospital Methodist and so
I had a costume easily my favorite
because I we went to this Pentecostal
church and it was all about the Holy
Spirit touching you and coming inside
you and talking toes flop on the floor
so I've seen that [ __ ] fascinate did
when I watch that I'm like this doesn't
look Christian this looks demonic right
yeah this is like the Jesus camp stuff
and so like there's even like which I
will I there's even like exorcism stuff
in my history because my mom was like
crazy and so but that all to me I'm a
victim of Munchausen's syndrome so how
much of that is [ __ ] right like how
much was that is just storage team and
manipulate me right I don't know but
here's something I can absolutely tell
you beyond the shadow of a doubt that
happened to me so my mom passed in 2009
and I always wanted to be the good kid
you know and I was the only one that
would do anything for her you know even
though I got the worst of it I for
whatever reason I could see the heart
out of monsters and I wanted to be there
for her when she died and so I get a
phone call one day and like you know
your mom is about to pass' at the
hospital if you you want to be here you
need to come and I pack up my all my
[ __ ] and I go there and I sat next to
her and hold her hand and she dies and
you know they give her morphine to help
her go I don't think a lot of people
realize that but they they'll give you
morphine and a lethal dose when they
know you're gonna like a little dose
give you a lethal amount of morphine are
you serious that's something that's very
common Lee I didn't know Lee
well enough to where your help basically
you're not you're almost not even
conscious at that point right right
you're not there right so like in the
case of my mother all of her organs had
shut down
she had three infections in her that
were not
reacting to antibiotics she's absolutely
going to die and her art is failing
right now so let's give her enough
morphine to wear when she dies tonight
she will die completely out of pain
she'll be completely unaware completely
comfortable I'm just saying she's
already in a medically comatose state at
that point anyway right so I held her
hand she died and I'll tell you I didn't
know what to expect but here's what
happened nothing just nothing she was
alive one second and she wasn't the next
and her body didn't change or transform
in any magic way there's no light there
was no poof there was no wind nothing
the machines showed that her heart was
beating one second and they showed they
were flatline the next that was it and
the nurses unhooked her and I sat with
her and i sat with her and i sat with
her and I again just kind of comesss I
don't know what I'm supposed to do you
know and they said he'd take as much
time as you want I'm like okay I don't
know how much time I would I don't know
what I'm doing but eventually my friend
Chad the guy who I told you help me keep
from being homeless enlist with us now
he came he was in the room and he's like
Steve we should go we got to make
arrangements and look okay and you know
we left and did everything and had to be
done and I came home and I was playing
World of Warcraft I decided the way I
was gonna cope with her death was to
throw myself back into that game make a
few friends and just play that game like
a drug until the pain stopped mm-hmm and
so that's what I was doing and I always
spent Christmas with my mom every year
this is the very first Christmas I would
ever spend alone now with a wife the
last Christmas left spent alone I'm
pretty happy about that but in fact in
retrospect it's the only Christmas ever
spent a long interesting and I'm setting
her playing World of Warcraft shirtless
I was so broke at the time I didn't have
an office chair I had a stupid broken
cooler I'd flipped upside down Wow also
set in Aaron's broken-down desk that's
broken down sharing this old ailing
computer and I feel a hand touch my
right shoulder
jump and I realize it felt exactly the
way my mom's had felt when I was holding
her now me and my mom had this
arrangement I have it all with all my
friends have it with my wife and
everybody else if there's an afterlife
you need to tell me if there is any way
you can communicate to me that there is
an afterlife you need to come and let me
know so that I can stop being a [ __ ]
nihilist and get my [ __ ] together ok if
it's Christianity let me know if it's
Muslim I need to [ __ ] know would you
ever want it is show up and tell me so I
can start doing that ok so that's the
deal
umm sorry I stayed up and I look around
the room and I go mom nothing mom
nothing so I set back down and I type in
the chat I'm like you're never gonna
believe what happened and I felt the
hand on my right shoulder again that's
weird so I knew not to turn around Oh
cry ha ha I knew not to turn around
because I know she's not gonna be there
anyway and I know on some level that
that's psychosomatic I know on some
level that's just me processing grief
where was it he like here right here on
the right shoulder I got it and I I you
know I I know on some level
psychosomatic I know on some level it's
just me my brain processing the pain and
figuring out a way to deal with it and
you know but at the same time I don't
know I do I know that like do I know
then why you asked you have this deal
with your mom do you think that she was
fulfilling it I don't know I honestly I
honestly don't know what that means I
wish I did I wish there was a moral to
that story I wish I could say I figured
it out it turns out we all have to eat
spaghetti every Thursday and that's how
we get in heaven I don't know but I know
I still to this day I don't know what it
meant I don't know what it was that's
why you know I have spoken to one
therapist about it and that therapist
has said it was you're probably right it
probably was psychosomatic you probably
imagine this scenario you know where you
sleep deprived during their time like
well I wasn't sleeping at all for like
weeks yeah that's probably part of it
it's just the grief process it strikes
us all every possible way but who knows
it's really interesting
a lot of the yeah that was thanks for
sharing that yeah a lot of the ghost
stories are
just you know there's no answer but yeah
there's no answer you can think of
reasons usually it's not I've felt that
before where it feels like someone
touched my shoulder yeah and I and I
don't know how to explain it it feels
like a spat maybe a spasm or something
like right maybe there's actually
something in your body that feels like
you're being touched
what specifically struck me was her hand
was cold as she died and so it was very
cold when you felt the temperature
temperature since action that's why
that's that's a good story
good luck sleeping everybody yes thank
you well I'll tell you what thanks for
joining us dude thank you for that ghost
story that was a legendary one y'all was
a real spoon that might be the top
spookiest ghost story we bet Wow okay
yeah I have to go find a compilation of
the rest it'll definitely come around
anyway I really appreciate you making
the trip out here is no no real as soon
as you started announcing a podcast am I
gonna be on that one day that's a bucket
list item right now and I can't believe
scratch it off yeah do you guys oh yeah
well definitely just do anything at
VidCon why do you guys not dude I don't
know I get the feeling we're not going
but we've never been invited we've never
been clearly this way yeah I don't know
how it works do you get invited or do
you well I think like so if you're with
an MCN I think sometimes James Ian will
pitch your name and if they're
interested then whatever I just wrote
the company like four years ago I'm like
hey I've always wanted to go to VidCon I
think super cool and are you guys
interested meters what I do right like
sure and so here's the thing like hey I
think a lot of people think that like
everybody ever talked like why don't you
try to go to VidCon on some level and
they're like I don't think they want me
as a featured creator whatever you'd
have been so perfect for the copyright
panel I did last year that I dropped
your name several times daring and
talking about your situation talking
about your suit talking about Fupa
talking about the whole nine yards and
all I could think that whole time was if
I didn't even know that was a thing you
know I I don't know it's it's we've
never really done the first con we did
was III and it was um dude was that this
year yeah was the hilarious one we
didn't make it inside actually
cut they're kind of late and like we got
there late we had like an hour there but
we getting stopped so many times it's
like a perfect overlap I think of our
fans yeah but we were getting stopped so
much that it was very much it was it was
more intense and I got the best feeling
in the world I swear it that's my
favorite man it was really it's really
flattering but other than like when like
it got to the point where there was like
a full circle around us and people kept
lining up do we have enough time for one
now I was like I'm [ __ ] I'm trapped I
was such a good I have no escape plan
okay
so last year I am at VidCon yeah and the
first year I went to VidCon it was
pretty cool like one out of five people
recognized me 150 people sometimes I can
just go on the floor and like I take one
selfie no be it yeah the next year a lot
worse the third the third year the third
time over last year and I could not go
into public area right and if I did I
would literally get that wall yeah um
and then on top of that security was mad
at me because this is right after the
Christina Grimmie shooting and they're
like super hyper aware and they can't
control that situation it's like you're
destroy your not supposed to be near the
public but it's the whole reason we're
yeah yeah yeah and but you know I mean I
didn't want to get uninvited so I
eventually started backing off and I did
have to go through a public area be like
I'm sorry we can't talk we can't talk
you know I'm sorry sorry you don't
apologize to something like this as I'm
walking or my little stupid remark our
thing so we David I lost my train of
thought so I'm this little they do this
little um meet and greet on the
convention floor so we can connect with
brands and brands can connect with us
because we weren't able to do that to
the rest of the show right and so I go
back to the bar and you never believe
who's there
markiplier Jack except a guy mm-hmm
jontron all sitting there drinking and
I'm like oh my god this is three people
right off the list I can't wait to talk
to all these guys and we hang out for a
little while we talk shocked here you
know Mark says some of the nicest things
to me so we end up we way we end up
going to the concert that night Gregory
Brothers
ain´t greens man is playing my wife's
favorite part is a concert
she's like watching her clock oh we need
to go we need to go and like hey guys
we're gonna split we're gonna watch the
concert you know if you anyways want to
come oh I'd love to everybody's super
excited so here's the thing I'm used to
my level of recognition I'm not used to
jacksepticeye hit mark at VidCon I can
imagine that's like Beatles mania like
Shh well show us the way so I show them
the way and it's all back a house until
we get right to the concert and I don't
know that there's like a place for us to
watch the concert I mean my wife I've
always just watched it from the audience
in the back right
so I lead them right into the center of
the damn thing mark is smart enough to
know pout and John is he's like peace at
this John is like I don't know what
happened to John cuz he was drinking a
lot I don't know if I saw what we uh but
Jack falls me in there yeah and so Jack
literally Beatlemania there are girls
putting flowers in his hair there are
girls handing him stuffed animals I
don't even think there's a lot of girl
work that's all girls it's all girls Wow
I don't even think they brought this
stuff for Jack I think they're literally
just taking things they own and giving
it I personally credit cards did I one
thing I consistently hear about VidCon
is that it's like super creepy it can't
be because it's just a bunch of little
wait that's aged that's it used to be
fetishizing break that's how you know
that used to be all it was like the
fourth year like four years ago yeah now
it's pretty much like a lot of younger
brothers and sisters so those girls have
grown up and so now there's a huge gamer
audience and there's a huge it's very
diverse now but at four years ago
absolutely but every girl that was at
that concert found Jack and so I look
over at one point and he looks at me
like this done to me I'm going to get
shot right and he's so sweet that he's
still signing away and he's taking gifts
oh thank god he's people trying to kiss
him and they're trying to touch him what
have I done to him so I walk over to the
security guy that grabbed him by the
shirt and I said dude where's the green
room and he goes hey bug
I don't know if you're allowed in the
green moon or not I I could find out
though and like not for me him mm-hmm
and I point to Jack and Jack looks at
the security got like I'm [ __ ]
drowning yeah there's no escape right
there's just stuck there so he then goes
grabs the two biggest security guards he
can find and then they literally just
saved jack
that's just like part the ways he's got
to go everybody's he's got to go I'm
sorry starting to go and oh I'm so sorry
oh I can't believe I don't know he can't
find me like you need he'd say we get
him to the back and this is why I like
telling the story yeah um we get him to
the back and I'm like dude I'm so sorry
I didn't realize that was gonna be like
that for yeah we normally just watch it
but it goes oh it's not a big deal but
he's just III can't sign all those
people I can't hug all those people and
I'm like well I'm sorry to put you in
that situation because well it's not a
big deal it's just it's just too damn
many of them I wish I could meet every
girl here but I just can't do it
and like I thought it was so sweet that
what he wasn't mad at me he's just
frustrated frustrated that he literally
can't people that's the situation I lose
that it's great yeah but it you're you
are confronted by this it's way too much
and you want to say hi to everyone you
want to take a selfie but it's like you
can't you have to you can't sit there
all day and the best part is you need
you need someone to like have your back
hey it's time to go and if you don't
want to be the guy that's like nice to
go you know and so I it is overwhelming
now and that's why like burning you
asked me if I wanted to come to RTX
roosterteeth and I'm like I don't think
I can dude because I think I'm gonna get
swamped they don't really have like I
asked if he's like a lot of
back-of-house stuff and he's like no not
really we're just gonna wade through it
I don't know that I could do that with
my social anxiety and stuff and but why
I tried to think of something markiplier
said whenever I meet in fans he said you
know if I meet somebody at VidCon it's
probably the thousand firth and I've met
at VidCon it's not important to me and
it's not that memorable to me but that
person might have bought a ticket just
to meet me that person is meeting me for
the first and maybe only time so I have
to get it right yeah and so that's what
I try to think this isn't about me I put
myself in a position where it's not
about me anymore
it's about this person so
we're gonna ask them their name I'm
gonna talk to them I'm gonna get to know
something about them I'm going to try to
remember them if I see them later at the
convention and it's over well he's just
so overwhelming but it's just again I
have to sleep at night and I got to know
I did the right thing yeah yeah I can
imagine
I can't imagine being your level of Fame
and then trying not let him get into the
building yeah we didn't we didn't quite
make I think it would have been even
worse than the building I mean we I
think we need to wear a disguise or
something if we do that again
cost-wise right yeah cosplay yeah do a
little spider-man Elsa all right let's
wrap we got it we got it let's got some
oh you have some appointment to go to
yeah so thank you man it was a joy it
was the honor was a privilege again if
you guys want to check me out
youtube.com slash boogie2988 yeah you
might like references sketches it's the
same vein kind of yeah and you might
also like what I do on Twitch because it
is way stranger what you do I'll tell
you that it's real [ __ ] up go to
Twitter check out his twitch I'm gonna
be watching [ __ ] you're selling it I
don't know it's like just get ready to
pucker your butthole the entire strip
buckers pure cringe alright guys thank
you so much for watching this little
impromptu episode appreciate you guys
coming onboard joining us you're with
buggy we will be back on Friday at our
usual time with steve-o spicy hot spicy
hot we'd have a sponsor this episode so
the best way to support us guys twitch
prime is that it I say right this time
twitch prime guys if you connect your
Amazon Prime with your twitch account
you can give us free money every month a
free subscription did you know that is
is amazing I love it and I will tell you
that is where the majority of much which
implies it's free way to support us
connect your Amazon account which
everybody has Amazon Prime rights are
free money every month thank you god
bless you guys so much and if you guys
go to represent calm /h virtually you
have two days left to buy this sick
merch that he was wearing why is
everyone saying scrapbook and oh is that
something my mom because my mom said
something about she wants everyone to
sign the scrapbook guys guys
so Ryder that my mom made this this
scrapbook I can't have everyone
scrapbook let's go just but I loved it
they all remember well let's what's here
I'm gonna grab the scrapbook immortalize
this yeah I'm sorry
my mouse goes like this and my mouth
goes like this I know I've always been a
guy who talks like a service yeah I met
people like that and it's so funny to me
I'm like I think she said there's empty
pages the ones like look at the
resolution that's so bad I love it it's
exactly the way I wouldn't want it to be
any other way
that's so good she actually went to
Staples
[Laughter]
you know honestly if you do that to me
I'm just gonna look normal yeah I'm not
gonna look thin I'm just like super look
at this it looks like Aiden looks like
an eight-year-old wrote it if you ever
get my signature if y'all want to fake
my signature just you have a stroke do
it with your offhand those are the best
natures yeah love the shadow on that too
by the way guys it's been a laughs it's
been a gaff
there's been some spook some ghosts lots
of spooks and sadly tons of spooks oh
yeah so we'll see you guys on Friday
thanks for watching poly plus thank God
it